I'm sorry for the delay folks we'll
foreign
welcome to public works I'm going to
open up the executive session on we're
going to start with House Bill 189
renaming a portion of Route 140 in
gilmington in honor of private first
class Nicholas Conyer I hope I'm not
mispronouncing is there anyone here to
speak well we're executive session I I
will uh
I will tell you I spoke with the author
on this last week
and uh told him that the representative
that the documentation we had from the
town uh wasn't sufficient uh it spoke
about that the executive uh
director for the town
was uh personally in favor of but it did
not say that the town
selectman I believe their select board
ruled was in favor and I asked them to
try and pull that document together for
today so that the committee could hear
that that's been a long-standing policy
of this committee and I told the
representative if we didn't have that
paperwork in hand today I would recess
the executive session and we'll we'll
pull it back in for next week but next
week would be the last opportunity to uh
to handle this matter
does anyone from the committee have
questions on that
yes representative a reminder Mr
chairman when is the deadline for this
the committee to report out all uh first
committee bills
I believe we have two weeks I will look
that up for you okay thank you Mr
chairman
so uh and and um
so any further questions at this time
okay with that I will uh close I will uh
recess the uh executive session on House
Bill 189 and we will add it to uh next
week's uh
uh executive session which will be
clearing the remainder of our our bills
I would like to
um to open up uh House Bill 296 for
executive session uh relative to local
Authority for granting driveway permits
and I would accept
uh representative Walsh has been working
with the um with the fire marshal on
this matter
um for several weeks at this time which
you have before you is uh amendment to
202307434 and I would move the adoption
seconded by um by represent clear
um and now we will open
[Music]
um
for discussion
I'd just like to say as I said briefly
um this this has been a conversation
back and forth
um representative Walsh as he is not
completely crazy about it
um uh is in favor of this amendment as
it was brought forward and it's a
compromise and
um
does anyone have questions on the
amendment is brought forward
I believe the fire chief originally was
looking for 14 feet
the homeowner had built
10p 10 feet and it was blocking the
permitting for them to get an occupancy
permit and so now this settlement is has
yes
yeah so this as I read it this is only
for
um one in one or two family dwelling
units so they don't they can still do
pretty much what they want with
commercial and multi-family
units the way this law reads and the
original one kind of excluded all of the
I'm I'm not sure the answer on that does
the original House Bill 296 is
introduced
just stopped or it said the provision of
the state fire code Associated rules
should not supersede the authority of
local land use boards on the planning
and zoning period
so now they've changed it to just only
apply to one and two family units
and that's I guess what we're voting on
now
that would that would be it
representative Newton
the fire chiefs were concerned about
apparatus access into single and two
family homes I gather
and it sounds like the 12 feet is enough
for vehicles to be traveling in and
outbound at the same time enough space
I
um
I I believe I believe at the 12 foot
where the average vehicle somewhere no
wider than eight foot six I think they
came to the conclusion that there was
enough room to pass by and not that
people that you could run two vehicles
in both directions thank you you're
welcome
yes
yes thank you Mr chairman for giving me
they built the opportunity to give you a
further comment one of the concerns I
had when the initial bill came up was
there was no discussion like what if a
driveway is only 30 feet from the road
and the fire trucks could park on the
side of the road for that matter but now
this amendment clarifies it the
driveways over 150 feet in length of the
12 foot so that gives me a little more
information than I had with the original
thank you
for representative purchase just joining
us the uh we
um we're working we've just passed an
amendment house bill 296.
yeah so he's you're coming in at this
point you're perfectly fine to uh
participate in the discussion in the
vote
so
all right
so if your face if you're in are there
any further questions on the amendment
as we have it now
all right so if you're if you're in
2023-0743h you'll signify by raising
thank you those opposed
record will show that the acceptance of
so hearing uh no further with the clerk
uh call the roll
you're in favor of the amendment you'll
signify by saying nobody's made a motion
oh I'm sorry thank you amended is there
someone they'll make a motion to pass as
amended
to move
thank you
second that motion yes
and seconded by Cloutier thank you for
any further questions
seeing none uh well the clerk will call
the role appear in favor of the uh House
Bill 296 is amended you'll signify by
saying aye and if you're opposed nay
um in the clerk will call
representative Mills clerk votes yes
representative fadolfi
representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski
represent representative Bowden
representative Boyd is not
representative Melvin yes
representative bogert yes
representative Connor I
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar is
representative Sykes
I
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton representative Peterson yes
representative vallone yes
the motion passes I'm sorry Mr the
chairman chairman hi thank you Mr Clark
almost missed you again
um the motion passes and represent Mr
chairman 17-0 thank you
our
last executive uh our last bill to exec
today is House Bill 606 FN require
requiring construction of State
buildings or state-funded projects to
contain electric vehicle EB charging
infrastructure infrastructure
Mr chairman I recognize Vice chairman
Cloutier I move ought to pass on House
Bill 606 and I wish to speak to my
um so um I was going to retain it
hey okay you want it rich
all right okay Mr chairman I've decided
I think there's been a discussion I
moved to retain house pill 606 please
chairman Cloutier moves to retain
um is there a second that second by uh
Mills
and
um
discussion would you like to speak and I
do wish to speak to my motion thank you
I've had uh some discussions with with
some member as this committee including
you Mr chairman and members of my caucus
and I think while there's a lot of
support for the for the principal of
this bill there are some members who
have indicated that because the way it's
written they're a little confused about
whether it's state buildings or
buildings that are that are financed
with State funds there's also the
question whether we're going to make any
money from the highway fund
I I sh but I still feel we need to do
something electric vehicles are are the
wave of the future the private sector is
already uh getting ahead of us I know
where I work up in West Lebanon doing
private security the company I I do
provide the security on a subcontract
but Nolo nordis has such hookups for
employees to hook in their vehicles I
know the Walmart in West Lebanon has
hook-ins the private sector is beginning
to provide that and I would say another
thing too we I think we need to work out
the Kinks
because I think one one of the thing
with the with the State Workforce we're
in a labor shortage and that includes
the state where uh Workforce and as far
as Recruitment and Retention this this
may be the difference between keeping or
a tracking plan I know you say well
that's crazy but you never know to be
able to charge your vehicle at work
rather than go to a gas station while
you're working I think maybe an
advantage
uh I I I feel too that if there are
there are details of this that need to
be worked out I would like to do that I
know we've retained another bill that
you and share uh chairman of the
chairman of the science technology entry
committee have
uh
are sponsoring and fine but I think we
need to do something about this issue
and we also need to consider raising
some Revenue as I said I'm on the
commission now that hopefully was was
created last year hopefully we recreate
it of course I don't know whether I'll
be on that commission but even if I'm
not I'm going to be pushing for
something to raise money for our
highways and this could be a small thing
to get started we may need to start
small because the commissions where it
may take a a year or two so I would at
the very least move that we retain this
bill we come back later in the in in the
year probably most likely in the early
late summer early fall and work on it
and maybe combine the best of of your
bill and chairman vose's bill with this
bill and hopefully come up with
something that later in the year we can
bring back to the Full House thank you
Mr chairman
thank you representative I would concur
with all the statements made by the Vice
chair I'd probably remove the word crazy
out of there but other than that I agree
with with everything the uh okay yeah
okay and and no not at all and um and uh
it's my hope that if we we retain these
and then we move forward with the
commission uh I think we can come out
with a better bill that will benefit
employers employees and people traveling
to uh to our state is there anyone else
wish to uh speak at this time
yes representative
Newman
yes uh just quickly
would it be possible when this is taken
up after it's retained to get to get
some information from whatever is the
best source of any and all state funded
housing projects that are maybe in the
yeah
so representative you're saying that we
when when we go to work on these bills
that we also consider
housing developments it was that your
five
and one any funded housing meeting the
definition of a project so I I just
wondered if that would be useful or at
least additional information as we go
forward not that it would stop anything
from going forward but if there's three
projects for instance in towns XYZ might
be useful to know okay I agree we can
pull that together for you yes
representative
Gaddafi in the Private Industry
those are going to become benefit to the
job
okay I don't see how this is ever going
to
produce
the time it takes to charge
money
the transportation department
because even if the state puts them in
the employee is going to expect the
state to pick up the tab the same way
that
uh businesses are doing
I promise and it's in places where they
have them it's just part of the job
they're getting as as a benefit to us I
don't see any
substantial amount of money going to the
thank you thank you for your comment yes
representative
I'm just um got a question
um
do we have any legislation that requires
gas stations to be built anywhere and I
have a follow-up to that if uh I may to
answer your question I do not believe
that's the case you had further question
yes so
if
the private sector has taken care of all
the fuel needs of automobiles at someone
else's expense and not the general
Public's expense then I'm kind of
curious why are we
wanting to get into the energy business
by making requirements that
the public sector itself
can take care of if there's money
because there's obviously money to be
made in this deal so I'm just curious
why we're interfering with the public
Commerce of electric vehicles
thank you I I think that was a would you
believe question to me
um and thank you and thank you for that
and hopefully by the end of this summer
beginning of of fall we're going to have
some answers for you on that at least
how far everyone's looking at this point
how far the federal government is is
going to participate in that cost and
grants and so forth yes representative
yes so this bill tries to lead that it's
all about
uh buildings and stuff funded by the
state yet the section two says single
family and duplex dwellings could
somebody tell me if the state is
involved in building single family and
answer is questions well noted
thank you
any other further yes RIP Sims thank you
Mr chairman the other thing I've been
confused about this bill uh since even
this morning I think it was clarified a
little bit on page two Roman 4 appears
to apply to any other state building
including Office Buildings particularly
uh in line five where it mentions trucks
uh so it would be good to clarify
whether this is you know State Office
Buildings are covered by by Roman 4.
thank you
I would say we get a little further out
here and get our capital budget perhaps
we would put together a subcommittee and
uh try and hash out or at least find the
questions that we want answered and I
think I've heard some good discussion
just uh remember you might those of you
who are here the on the 24th I did ask
Charlie arlinghaus about charging
stations being the department of
administrative services and of course I
think he his answer wasn't totally what
I wanted but he said there's plenty of
money out there it sounds like the state
is going to begin to apply for those
federal funds to hopefully install those
charging stations
in State Office Buildings around that
the buildings they manage around the
state but I think this bill one of the
reasons I'm sort of uh in favor of this
bill is to give them an incentive to do
that uh but I realize that it's going to
be retains but so I think the state is
beginning to make efforts but I think
this bill will if it was to pass in some
form we combine it with uh the chairmans
and representative Moses Bill we would
encourage them even further thank you
yes representative Connor
yeah um now these charging stations that
might possibly be built are they going
they're going to be um
have adapters for different style
Vehicles because like I know the Tesla
takes a different one and like Chevy
takes a different one so I'm just
probably pointing that out maybe you
might want to you know look into that
too yeah Point well taken okay
representative
I I will just we have a couple minutes
just for further information
um I own a um
convenience store gas operation
we were approached by the state last
year
because we're on a major Corridor North
and they were trying to get in the first
round of funding X number of stations X
number of miles my area was identified
as one of those
um we and there was money in that
program to upgrade our infrastructure to
bring the power out to and so forth uh
it seemed a little too costly for us at
this point in time so we didn't move
forward but there are also um
other agents out there then to come in
and say if if you don't want to move to
that expense at that point they'll
become a subcontractor they'll they'll
take care of the infrastructure and send
us a few pennies back every year and at
that point in time it didn't seem the
right goal for us but I'm going to say
that there is a lot of activity and I
believe there are two or three rounds of
this money out there so one way or the
other it's going to happen so it'd be
good if we participate in in how that
happened so
so if there's no further discussion
motion's been made and has been seconded
on House Bill
606 FN
and if the
if you're in favor of the motion to
retain then you'll signify by saying aye
if you're opposed nay
and with that the clerk will call the
roll
Mr representative Cloutier yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative adolfi yeah
representative Newton yes
representative Kaczynski
representative Bowden
representative Boyd representative
Melvin yes representative bogert yes
representative Connor
aye
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Sykes
I
representative Newman yes
representative Peterson yes
representative balone yes representative
jurist
aye
the motion to retain passes Mr chair
17-0
thank you so
um with the exception of um
189 which we
um will hear next week we have concluded
our yes
um just on some other business yes
please we didn't determine whether we
wanted to have
House Bill 296 put on the consent
calendar or not oh thank you
is there objection to putting it on
consent
um
representative that was it thank you for
that both gentlemen
um so we are
um
our next hearing will be with uh
Treasury Department at 10 o'clock so
bring it in
this
we will um we will move to our uh first
uh hearing
and we will bring the treasurer uh
forward and please have a seat introduce
yourself
and I apologize for not taking a shot at
your last name and
um welcome to Public Works and uh it's a
pleasure to have you here
we in the committee in the past we would
start off with the treasurer and the
scheduling did not work for us so we've
heard from a few department heads so I
think it's it's very appropriate timing
uh now that we have this discussion and
uh
thank you once again for being here good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record State
Treasurer Monica mazzapelli and just a
quick disclaimer I I had a virus last
week so I'm supposed to keep my mask for
a few more days so but if there is
anything that I said you would like me
to repeat or or go over again I'll be
happy to do that
um so thank you Mr chairman and um
so today I was invited to talk about
um that affordability so I'm gonna try
to just walk you through the things that
we look at in the treasury and I'll try
to stay at a higher level
but if I lose anybody please don't
hesitate to ask me
so I will um so I provided a handout
[Music]
um
and I will probably start with
and really the treasury
um looks at on data affordability and
two different ways one we um we prepared
a data affordability study every year
and we work with the state's financial
advisor to um to put the study together
and we do this every year so you're
probably familiar with with what we do
here but to study what what this what
this work does is really we current a
bunch of numbers we um we get some
actuals and then we project some debt
metrics that allows us to see and
evaluate how the state is doing in terms
of its debt profile so we calculate you
know certain metrics and the ones we
look at is a debt to personal income
debt per capita and the most important
one that we look at is on that service
to uh to revenue ratio and those are the
the metrics that um that we review every
year
um the other sort of tool that we have
is prescribing statue and that's an RSA
6c2
and that um you know that really
prescribes how much debt the state can
afford and we're supposed to calculate
this amount and and also certify to the
legislative budget assistance that this
is the amount that um essentially the
legislature can only
um authorize up to that number so what
the law says is the legislature can
author cannot authorize
that is in excess of 10 of unrestricted
Revenue so that's that service paid with
we call it net tax supported debt or
Debt Pay with General funds and that's
actual and projected that service so we
need to determine how much are actual
Debt Service we also need to project our
debt service
and then we need to compare it to 10 of
under restricted Revenue again it's a
calculation and what that does is really
the statutory limit how much does the
state can
um
can borrow essentially
um that is a little bit of high in our
view but it's still in status it
provides a guardrail how much the state
can borrow can borrow
um for capital projects
so um on page three I quickly
um I can walk you through some of the
the rages and metrics that we look at so
every year we we've been August for for
the last several years the treasury has
been used in this number about 120
million in Born authorizations so we
take that number and we say we're gonna
see what this does to our debt metrics
so we've been consistent over time and
so we are assuming that we're going to
issue about 60 million dollars in bonds
every year to pay for the capital
projects are authorized by all of you
and you uh you all have the difficult
tasks to approve the Corporal budget
that's really my job is really to Crunch
a bunch of numbers to help you with that
decision right and so
so in the study we assume that we're
going to issue 60 million every year and
then we we see what those you know how
those ratios perform and um so again for
for this year this is just a quick
summary of what the study shows but
um in 22 we're project you were
calculating the the debt metrics of
um
um well the first line is actually our
total
um outstanding debt so that's showing
um 507 million dollars in net tax
supported that and fiscal year 22 and
then
um again the projection is assuming that
we're going to issue 60 million each
year we project on that service all the
way to 26 and by 26 it looks like I'll
send the debt will be about 516 million
so with that number then we start
calculating the other important ratios
and we're using um
debt to personal income
um as probably you all know personal
income in in New Hampshire is strong so
um we're using the actual figure that
was published in 2021 and we obtained
that figure from the Bureau of economic
analysis so we use that personal income
and then we're projecting for the rest
of the the fiscal years from 23 to 26 we
project that that personal income is
going to grow about four percent each
year and those are the ratios that that
are calculated
same with that per capita
right now the population is about 1.3
million we'll obtain that figure from
the U.S Census Bureau and then we
project that for the over the next few
fiscal years the population is going to
grow about 0.5 percent every year and
that's been consistent in his
historically and that's how we're com
we're calculating those numbers
um and the same with that that service
to Roman ratio again that's the that's
the metric that we pay more attention to
um 10 is what the rating agencies look
at and they say 10 is excessive that's
also the number prescribed in the
statute but but again that's sort of our
our threshold the limit so we always
want to calculate or we want to be at a
number or a ratio that is way below that
10 Mark and so as you can see
um the bottom line in 2022 we have a
debt to revenue ratio of four percent so
the state is doing excellent
um with with their debt to Urban ratio
and this is because we've had
um
uh Revenue performance has been again
outperforming over the last couple of
years and
the the the the
projections that we have for the debt to
run a ratio we actually use very
conservative Revenue projections from 23
to 26.
um I always say my job is not really to
predict Revenue my job is to really
stress our ratios to see you know how
you know if revenues were not performing
as well how will our debt profile look
like so so again we're using in this
study very conservative
um
um revenue forecast the theme in 23 we
use a one percent
um growth rate and then in 24 we we
actually had a decrease we used a
decline of one percent and 25 we said
well there will be no Remnant growth and
then it was a a 0.5 growth and and 26.
again I'm just just stressing our debt
profile here but again even with those
numbers
um you know using the assumption that we
will use about that we will issue about
60 million each year
that's how the ratios perform
so that's a sort of quick overview of
what we do we also in the study we we
stress our our debt profile in different
ways we include all the debt the state
that's guaranteed to other authorities
and municipalities so we include those
those
um that debt assuming that the state
were to assume all of that day we
included in the calculation to see how
those ratios change but again even with
those stressors or even using more um
um
um I guess lower Revenue assumptions we
at this moment the the ratio is way
below the 10 and that's how we want to
um
so perhaps I want to stop there to see
if there are any questions I could just
continue to maybe leave questions at the
end
any questions at this point my My Hope
Is we will go through the majority and
then I think questions will come in does
anyone have any questions at this time
please continue man absolutely
so the next page is is you know again
the calculations that we do for for the
um for the debt limit prescribed in our
says 6C and and again this is just
trying to determine
um how much more anal that service this
day could afford so again it's a it's a
bunch of numbers that we we crunch here
but we essentially use our current the
First Column is just shine our actual
Debt Service and the second column is
including um
um we're assuming that we're going to
issue all of The Debt Service that has
been authorized and unissued we haven't
issued those bonds and that's about
360.5 million of of
authorizations and then we also include
all the guaranteed debt uh debt that the
state guarantee for other authorities
like the business Finance Authority and
other municipalities and then we we
calculate this total projected debt We
compare to the 10 percent of our
restricted revenue and the last column
really shows if you look at the
highlighted amount or the Bullet amount
it looks like in 24 we could actually
afford another 100 million of Debt
Service according to this calculation so
what that mean is you know the state
could actually issue or authorize
another billion dollars 1.2 billion
dollars but again that will reach the 10
threshold that we really don't want to
reach but again this is a career
relation we have to prepare it by
Statute we have to prepare this amount
and also certify it to the legislative
budget assistant this is a preliminary
numbers actually we're I'm using it for
for this presentation but we still have
to verify some of this numbers so that
we haven't provided that uh to to
legislative budget assistant but we're
about to do that in the next few days
we'll get those numbers done
um so that's what that does so we again
we we review that affordability
um
and again we use the 120 million sort of
um number and has been used over the
last several fiscal years I think in the
past it was 125
um 120 really as what we use and it's
it's just showing a predictable
um
is a predictable number that you're
going to see as part of that service to
to show your debt service
um so page five is just I included you
know several considerations so why do we
care about all of this
um well the reason we care about keeping
our ratio slow and we do this because
um or borrowing costs are really
influenced by our our credit rating so
we want to make sure that our debt
profile of what the state the the states
that policy remains consistent remains
strong in order to you know this is just
a component of what the rating agencies
look at and so maintaining that
stability and our debt profile
um healthy allows us to have a good um
credit rating so the rating agencies
also look at all the things and and
that's what I included in this page they
look at the levels in the rainy day fund
um they want to see that the state has a
um a structured budget is able to
balance the value budget
um in also the rate I just also look at
the budgetary pressures created by
Medicaid pension and post employment
um uh payments and expenditures
they look at the stability and diversity
of our Revenue sources so in New
Hampshire we have several different ways
we collect Revenue here so that's
another positive uh credit positive we
call it and also they look at you know
how much flexibility this day has to
manage the revenues expenditures and uh
and Reserve levels and the funding
relative to the general fund to um the
rainy day fund
so essentially our our
um
debt levels and that their management
practices are considered credit positive
it's just one of those things that the
reigning agencies don't really worry too
much about when it comes to New
Hampshire
also as you can see the ratio has
improved over time so I'm including the
ratio over the last 10 years and you
know back in 2013 it was 7.7 percent it
increased slightly in 24 2015 that was
because
um there was this change in the Medicaid
enhancement tax was
prior to 2014 it was considered
restricted Revenue so then it switched
to restricted in that obviously changed
the calculation but then after that it
started decreasing over time it
increased slightly and um
in 2020 because of the economic crisis
caused by the pandemic but then with 21
and 22
so on page six it's just part of what I
just wanted to to quickly mention
obviously as you all know boring costs
are higher than I expected to remain at
that level for some time
also as a reminder of perhaps this is
not something you track as as much as I
do but um we have currently or at the
end of fiscal year 22
there was
316.5 million of bonds authorized in an
issue that means that's something you
already authorized and prior budgets but
we have not issued them yet we have not
issued bonds yet because the
expenditures for those projects have not
occurred or or they've been delayed so
this sort of what we've been seeing
lately
um and just obviously as a general
comment maintaining um
you know borrowing a borrowing capacity
maintenance a strong capacity to borrow
is also a healthy and as prudent you
know that way you can consider an
anticipated Capital needs or priorities
that um a part of you know the
essentially what this current budget or
House Bill 25 is trying to trying to do
so that way you have the ability to to
make those decisions
and lastly I just wanted to include our
ratings just so you you have them uh
this day has strong credit ratings
um it last year SMP changed the state's
a look Outlook from
stable to positive and that is because
the rating agencies can keep seeing the
state how the economy is growing
um the economy is strong and also they
like the idea that the state put more
money into the rainy day fund the rainy
day fund is a key component because they
see that as a measure of how the state
is going to be able to respond in times
of economic downturns so again
maintaining liquidity
um
structural budget you know having a
it gives a strategy to manage the
financial position of the state is is
what the rating agencies like to see
the last page is just included you know
where we WE Post all our Publications
online so I just wanted to mention that
as a reminder
so that's what I wanted to just cover
today as part of you know how we this
treasury looks at that affordability
again we just calculate a lot of numbers
for you and I know this is also
um this is how we come up with the idea
of
um the 120 million that we typically
include in our calculations I'll be
happy to answer any questions thank you
for that overview and we'll take
questions moment
um this committee has for the most part
over the 20 years or so back and forth
that I've been here has been comfortable
with this deciding capital projects and
our numbers have been fairly close to
that hundred and twenty million dollars
there were years it was a little less
and so forth but I believe last time
around 120 million dollars could you
tell me
and it's troubling me
is that projects that normally would
come through our committee are being
heard directly in finance
and that's that's none of your uh your
issue but my question is
if there was legislation this last week
to create a fund for water quality of 25
million dollars
and there was another project which is
part of the I-93 project Exit 14 as it
was generally x4a that there was another
bill that came through that comes close
to adding uh 900 000 onto a project
and it's it's troubling to myself and
I'm sure people on my committee is that
going to affect our capital budget or do
you have some other secret pot of money
out there that that those projects could
be drawn from
thank you Mr chairman is a great
question it really has to it needs to be
included as part of this overall bonding
authorization so even if you approve a
number 120 125 but if on the side there
are other bonding authorizations that's
part of this whole equation it really
has to all be considered so it really is
a state as a whole how much
the state
um wants to bond and so obviously we
Bond based on authorization so you
authorize 120 the other numbers need to
come together so the
every other year so or sometimes we see
those
um there are some authorizations that
happen during an off cycle
um you know the capital budgets
authorized and then the next fiscal year
some other product is is authorized so
we need to track that we need to really
uh verify that that authorization that
we consider that as part of what we are
calculations so yes the quick answer is
yes it needs to be considered they um if
if I could on the guaranteed debt uh UNH
has had a couple different capital
projects that have run over a term of
four or five years and I believe this
year it comes to a conclusion we're
about to hear from them we'll hear what
their plans are but and I believe it was
17 million dollars drawn down this time
is is the UNH money when that happens is
that considered part of the guaranteed
debt
so two things so so the quick answer is
not guaranteed that anything that we
Bond or that is part of the capital
budget we consider that
we pay that with General funds so
anything that is so the 17 million that
was already
authorized in a
so I guess two parts to your to
two answers it's not guaranteed that and
that 70 million was already authorized
so it doesn't have to be included in
this years
um
bonding authorization okay if if I could
Madam chairman so that's 17 million
dollars was general fund and not bonding
money
well it's paid with general fund meaning
is so the this the term of guarantee the
term of State guarantee that's that's
really when um the state for example the
the the the easy easiest example is the
business Finance Authority they they are
authorized to issue bonds but then the
state backs that with the fulfilling
credit of the state if if the business
and Finance Authority can't pay those
bonds that's that's what we consider
um
um guaranteed debt with the UNH debt
that is direct that is that is that that
the state has
um promised to pay on behalf of
um university system of New Hampshire so
okay that's that's that's the state debt
I guess I'm gonna call it okay thank you
the
so the question will come up from the
new members and some of the others so we
we have a that 60 million dollars that
we're dealing with and 120 cumulative uh
the question's been asked in the past
that if that tweaked a million this way
or a million that way or five million
dollars that that probably not
considering all this other debt that
they're trying to throw in US probably
isn't an issue but when you start
getting I believe the number we've heard
in the past you start getting out past
15 million or so then it starts to
I
I've heard it really doesn't so a few
million so to answer your question a few
million won't won't change the number I
know in the past I think it was last
during the last biennium it was about
130 million that was authorized so that
doesn't really change
um we we're not concerned about that
just because
um the ratio as you can see even when we
stress it done much it doesn't really
change that much so it's it's just a
matter of your decision so again we just
use this number to show how these
calculations will look like it is really
your policy decision how much you want
to authorize so
um I think when it starts when we need
to really start considering um you know
how the the true impact as we start
talking about approving an additional 50
million for example uh put a few extra
five or ten perhaps may not change the
calculation that much thank you thank
you representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you Treasurer I just
want to make sure I understand the 17
million uh that's already baked into the
debt in the same way that a lapse
extension is baked into prior
authorized debt so we don't have to
consider that we don't have to add that
to the to the number that that's in
section one
which is 120 almost 113 million so we
wouldn't be adding that we can go ahead
and authorize the 112 without worrying
about the 17
being added to it because it's already
baked in am I understanding that
correctly I believe that's that's how I
understand it as well it has been
authorized already and I believe it's
just being included this year as a
reminder that that was already
authorized in a previous budget
yes represent bark
uh thank you Mr chairman uh I'm not
quite sure how to ask the question but
as
we go through legislation that has or
will probably reduce revenues through
different bills and stuff that are uh
in process as it goes does that have an
adverse effect to the debt limit that we
can carry through this RSA
6-c colon 2.
yeah thank you for the question I think
obviously any any changes in revenues
will have
uh we'll change this calculation so
um it could be it could be some of the
changes that are being implemented it
could be an economic downturn so
anything that is um that would change
essentially the the denominator will uh
will impact this calculations so
um
it is unclear how those changes I don't
believe that if you're talking about
Revenue
perhaps some well just for instance if I
may miss a chairman
um
like the gas tax there was a bill
floating around wanting to remove four
pennies per gallon there's removing the
communications tax their re you know
there's different things that are trying
to be implemented uh uh for tax savings
and stuff like that but does that come
with a caveat of a
issue on the percentage of debt
calculation
of that so the quick answer I think it
would be it could impact
um the calculations
um
only if it impacts unrestricted Revenue
so for example if you're talking about
certain uh changes to
um the highway fine that will not impact
this calculation it only is
unrestrictive revenue anything that
impacts unrestricted Revenue could
potentially impact this calculation
um to that to the actual impact it's
unclear to me how how that it just comes
as a the overall package again of how
much unrestricted Revenue will change
hopefully that answer your question
you're welcome thank you any further
questions
seeing yes
representative Malone thank you Mr
chairman uh and thank you for testifying
today so what's your uh assumption
regarding interest rates uh that's based
goes into these calculations here I see
the feds possibly going raising the
rates up to five and a quarter so could
you please talk about that thank you yes
that thank you for the question um as
yes absolutely the the the
rate environment is changing is um so we
we're using um rates for tax and set
exempt bonds this is a municipal Market
but even the um the municipal Market
those interest rates are changing what's
the changes that the Federal Reserve is
is making oh you know a spot of again
increasing rate so
um so it does impact it does impact a
um the municipal bond market follows the
treasury market so um the yields are
increasing so we're looking at rates
right now and again it's this is this
changes it's all dependent of how the
market is performing but we're looking
at rates in the range of close to four
percent
um in in from what I hear from our
financial advisor is that perhaps we're
going to go back to times of uh you know
back in um prior to 2008 the rates were
about four percent in that you know
neighborhood and they will probably stay
like that for some time so we'll see
this pressure you know we've been
borrowing really
um uh inexpensive we've been able to
borrow
um it's been inexpensive to borrow in
the past so now we really have to
consider that as part of our overall
cost and again that's brought that's why
I wanted to include it in my
presentation and mention it just because
um it will impact
um our budgets you know how much we we
have been included in higher interest
rates in these calculations so
essentially it will it will certainly
impact our budgets current budgets and
upcoming budgets
thank you representative Abbott
yes thank you Mr chairman
um I just wondered
um under the credit ratings for the
state it has Moody's Fitch and standard
s p I recall from the last time we did
this capital budget and the lending that
there was some kind of difficulty with
standard and pause and has that been
resolved
it has uh representative thanks for the
question and in the past there was this
uh
um the rating agency was just using what
we call all language and their you know
evaluation and they were using um
um that's part of what they were
um using as a foundation what they were
looking at the the in the treasures view
it was it was seen as probably
inaccurate or older information they
were using for the analysis so
um it was about three years ago I think
we we met with them we explained to them
so
um they they have been obviously
consider our our feedback our input and
since then uh they've been more
um uh obviously uh using more relevant
information information that we share
with them they've been considering that
information and again um you know to to
the point that they were able to change
the Outlook they they use their Outlook
as a as a way to see
if their look is stable then they say
okay well this you know this state or
this uh issuer is going to
um
I guess remain stable remain consistent
over time when they change the uh the um
when the changes are locked from stable
to positive there really is it really is
a sign that they perhaps considering an
upgrade so they're giving us some
conditions as to
um you know what they will do I guess
conditions if the state performance this
particular manner for example continue
adding to the rainy day fund continue
with The Debt Service um the debt
management practices you know certain
things that we're doing well and then
you know keep working on the things that
we're not doing as well they will
consider giving us an upgrade
um so so yes to answer your question yes
we have resolved that that you should do
any other further questions at this time
I'm Treasurer I want to thank you so
much for being here today thank you
thank you very much Mr chairman it's a
pleasure
uh we for the University system welcome
uh we'll start in just one moment let me
we will uh we will now move on the
University system of New Hampshire
um we we in this committee over the
course of many years have had several
chairmans of chairman show up and come
and go and we're always acknowledging
for the new members accounting
provincial was former Treasurer am I
correct
State of New Hampshire also please come
forward and uh
present the University's capital
good morning chair McConkey and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Catherine provencher I serve as the
chief administrative officer and vice
vice Chancellor of Finance for our
state's University system Matt Purcell
is director of capital planning for
really for Plymouth and Keene
coordinates their work and Bill Janelle
is the assistant associate vice
president
for facilities and administration over
at UNH so we have some material for you
we have a few slides to walk through
knock that we have more slides probably
than than we need to cover in a half an
hour but I'd like to just
um kind of remind members of the
committee who have been here for quite
some time and it sounds like you've
already spoken to the to the state
treasurer about the appropriation that
was made in 2019 on slide one we just
give the excerpt in 2019 the capital
budget provided for three biennium
Appropriations for the University system
which excuse me
has been extremely helpful in our
planning and what projects we can do in
what projects we can't do it's had a
meaningful impact on the our Capital
planning on on slide two
in the green columns this was the
breakdown of the state Appropriations
that were again were made in 2019 and
then the portion of those projects that
has been have been funded by the
university system and we made a
commitment at that time that if projects
went over
we were not going to come back and ask
for more money and you can imagine
over that time period with inflationary
pressures and supply chain issues we
have had especially at the biological
sciences initiative at UNH and Bill will
talk about that in just a minute
on slide three as you're well aware all
agencies are required to provide a
six-year Capital plan and so while the
state request for fiscal years 24 and 25
is to remain where we um are right now
from the laws of 19 we have included
slide four I want to just um
inform the committee on the entirety of
the University Systems Capital plan the
state piece is impactful
but the vast majority of the capital
dollars that are expended by the
university system on our Capital plan
our University system funded
um we we pretty much run three little
cities and with dorms and dining halls
and academic buildings and
Athletics and all of that
um
the majority of the capital dollars are
funded by the university system so
that's what that pie chart shows and and
Gibson grants as well Gibson grants is
the um the biological sciences
initiative at UNH is the largest Capital
project ever undertaken by the
university system and correct me if I'm
wrong I believe over the three biennium
appropriation
35 million of the 95 million dollar
project
is and was funded by state
Appropriations
so I am going to let Bill Janelle talk
more about the the um the project itself
okay thank you Kathy uh good morning
representative McConkey and members of
the capital budget overview committee so
this biological sciences initiative is
essentially a renovation of Spalding
Hall in addition to Spaulding Hall the
addition comprises about forty seven
thousand square feet and the renovation
is about 83 000 square feet and Spalding
Hall is a 1960s vintage science building
that we're upgrading to today's
standards so a few things that this
project will do number one it's going to
address significant deferred maintenance
in that building to the tune of about 30
million dollars
it will also increase enrollments in
these high demand science Fields it it
will upgrade our laboratory and teaching
spaces that again 1960s building doesn't
meet today's needs with the goal of
increasing Workforce the workforce in
this area for for many companies that
so just a quick overview of the project
and this I'm on page slaw page seven and
that photo is a a picture of the Edition
so the project budget as Kathy said 95.5
million our architect is Ellen swag
Associates the construction manager is
skanska and the delivery method is
construction manager at risk
the project was started in September of
2019 and we started with the addition
which is Phase One and again I'm on
slide eight and if you look at the
schematic on that on that slide the
lower picture shows the blue area is
actually the addition and the tan area
is existing Spalding Hall and phase one
is the addition again which was it was
completed in April of 22 so roughly
about a year ago
we signed the guaranteed maximum price
in January of 21 for phase two which is
the renovation of Spalding Hall and that
work began in January of 20 of June of
22 I'm sorry and we're targeting
completion for spring of 2024 with
occupancy of the entire facility in the
fall of 2024. so this project again has
been going on since 2019 where we've
been building through the pandemic we've
certainly had some challenges as Kathy
said with materials and delays and we
had to stop work at one point as well
but we do remain on budget and we've had
schedule has slipped a bit but only a
few months at this point and again we're
looking to occupy in the fall of 2024.
so on slide nine
the project will deliver 11 biological
science teaching labs and nine research
labs and accommodate an additional 50
principal researchers we're also
constructing a vivarium within the new
project so that's a housing for
laboratory animals rats and mice and
that the vivarium will also be completed
at the same time as the rest of the
project in Fall of 2024.
so on slide 10 these are just some
photos of work currently underway so
phase one that shows some of the lab
spaces that are completed and occupied
right now and in use
and phase two is below and this spring
we did a complete gut demolition of
Spalding Hall
and we did find more hazardous materials
asbestos mainly in that facility than we
were anticipated but we're continuing to
move forward with instructional
reinforcement complete replacement of
the mechanical electrical and plumbing
systems
um so it's underway and going well
there are I'm sure if if the committee
was ever interested I'm sure the
university would love to have you over
for a tour but
um there are also two impactful projects
at Plymouth and at Keene and Matt
Purcell is just going to briefly give
you an update on those
yeah good morning just to briefly update
you quickly if you don't know Plymouth
State University start off with Hyde
Hall it's a Hyde Hall is the primary
academic facility on that campus it was
built nearly 50 years ago in that
interim that many students have gone
through it and we're proposing to a
project there to address a lot of the
mechanical electrical problems in some
of the envelope issues that we have with
that building
uh currently anticipating it will
address at least 17 million dollars of
of Maintenance backlog in there as well
as creating and revitalizing the
business school and creating more of an
applied business approach uh for their
undergraduate and graduate student
programs there this is going to Prime
the project is going to primarily focus
on the first and second floor although
the the maintenance or the mechanical
systems are going to address the entire
building
the
intent of the creation of this
Innovation Center on the first and
second floor of this business Innovation
Center is to make more connectivity with
the businesses within the North country
and to provide a greater diversity of
Workforce that will go directly into the
into the economy of New Hampshire
um
we're well underway on the project we
just completed the design last week and
uh have a
preliminary guaranteed maximum price
contract of 30 points well the total
project of 30.5 million dollars with a
with a guaranteed contract with a
contractor uh Engelbert construction for
about 25 million dollars the uh
the architect on the project is a firm
out of Boston called goody Clancy
um right now we anticipate that we are
going to do a phased construction
starting with the fourth floor and
moving down to the first floor over 16
months starting in May and completing
most of it in by the end September 2024.
right now it's uh
it's how we're going to sequence and
move all the students through the
building as one of our current Endeavors
right now and and be able to occupy it
and do the construction at the same time
next project is the Elliott Center down
at Keene State College right now we're
in the procurement process of engaging a
a architectural firm it's going to be a
20 million dollar project which is going
to address the student services needs on
that campus Central centralizing them as
well as improving the admissions office
and and the supporting uh
building the Elliott was it used to be a
hospital the college
purchased it in 1971 did some minor
Renovations then uh has not had any
major Renovations since that point in
time and this is going to address a
significant amount of the the
maintenance backlog in that facility and
we anticipate that we're going to start
the construction of that in early summer
we were asked to include information on
any capital projects that were included
in house bill 2. and so beginning on
slide 20
.
in section 10 of House Bill 2
there is eight million dollars to be
funded I Believe by Sir Surplus in
fiscal 23 to go toward the Whittemore
Center at unh
and Bill can talk specifics about this
the governor believes that this is an
impact what we do do as well an
impactful project
the university has already invested
um heavily I think we replaced the
entire ice and everything underneath it
in the last couple years and then we're
now working on HVAC and
um so we also have they're also donors
that are willing to participate in the
project and so bill has more information
on the project itself
thanks Kathy
um
okay so if many folks I'm probably
familiar with the whitemore center but
this is the home of the men's and
women's hockey programs at UNH and also
the Northeast passage sled hockey team
at UNH which has produced many
paralympic
um athletes that go to to those games
but the project uh it's envisioned to
invest 30 million dollars into the
Whittemore Center address deferred
maintenance needs and upgrade the
facility to meet current standards the
improvements will bring the facility on
par with other higher ed peers and also
allow for host additional utilization of
the facility in the spring summer and
fall of periods as well
and the funding as Kathy said
um we're looking at funding from UNH
private philanthropy and hopefully the
state as well
so on slide 21 and 22 we kind of break
up the different components and the
funding piece so unh's commitment is
about 13.7 million and there's two
pieces to that one is
um his work that's just been completed
is a 6.5 million dollar project where we
replaced the ice sheet so the the
concrete slab and Refrigeration under
the slab along with the ice making
equipment
um the Dasher boards as well and also
the sound system which is will be
replaced this spring so that work is
just completing now UNH also has a
project to upgrade existing the existing
HVAC system and add air conditioning to
the rink level as well so that was never
installed when it was initially built in
1995.
so the other components are to renovate
team spaces throughout the Whittemore
Center and also add a strength and
conditioning Center to the facility
and again this this would include locker
rooms for men's hockey women's hockey
field hockey as well and it would also
create a fully accessible locker room
for the north Northeast passage sled
hockey team
so on slide 23 just essentially gives
you a couple of schematics one at the
rink level where all that colored area
represent those team rooms and
conditioning spaces as well that would
be renovated as part of the project and
the lower
um
plan shows in addition in red which
would be the strength and conditioning
area that would be included as well and
on the right just provide some photos of
those spaces so on top that's a that's a
view of the back side of the Whittemore
Center where that strength and
conditioning area would be added and
we've got a photo of the locker rooms
and also the strength and conditioning
area
and on slide 24
um
the graph that's here essentially shows
uh
where UNH stands with peers for strength
and conditioning space so we're
currently the lowest when when you look
at that space in itself the blue bar
just to the right of that will show
where UNH would be when this project
would be complete so still kind of in
the middle of the road where that line
is shown horizontally would be that
would be the center line
um
so that's kind of a high level summary
and the only thing I'll add is
um the additional utilization of the
facility it's it's used for a high
school programs it's used for our
commencement we've hosted presidents
there as well so it's much more than
thank you all for the overview
I appreciate that
um
I would like to go back
um start back with a
Career technical schools
um and others have partnered with
[Music]
um
with work Workforce
with business I'm thinking of the HVAC
program and specifically labs for that
purpose
automotive and others you piqued my
interest when you spoke that you were
going to be working with some of the uh
the tech leaders in our state and this
being part of that and could you tell me
or any or any of those
uh corporations working on this or any
of those corporations contributing money
and those corporations saying we have
such a need here that we are willing to
help with labs and so forth or are we
developing
a program that works in general
everywhere
uh
the one company that comes to mind is
lonza who we've worked with initially
they were here to even speak to this
project and they're looking to hire many
of the graduates and there is I believe
there is some funding coming from lonza
to support the project as well not to
the level of completing an entire lab
space but there is Select funding within
the project for that purpose but that's
the one that comes to mind where they
have you know Pharmaceuticals and by and
biology
students that they'd look to bring on
board thank you for that so our once
this lab's finished and this will be a
great Jewel for the University
what sort of work will you be doing
there and do we have any thoughts as are
we training
are we gaining Prestige by having this
facility or are we training people to go
work throughout the country and not in
so I uh let me answer your first
question uh representative Conte I think
it absolutely will bring Prestige not to
just the university but to the state
um our peers around around New England
are investing in these same types of
facilities
we I can tell you that
our students that participate in
internships are twice as likely to stay
and work here
and the university has invested heavily
in a
they call it caps career and
it's it's a career advising placement
office
um there are more internship
opportunities available now to UNH
students than actually students
actually part of our operating request I
know this is capital is to invest in
those same types of efforts at Plymouth
and Keene to really ramp up internship
Business Partnership so I will say that
absolutely we hope to keep our graduates
working
staying here in New Hampshire
um
but that's not just a university system
effort right that's an effort on the
part of
business and state and the university
system in keeping our students here
um I I think what it will do is attract
students here that might not have
otherwise been attracted to
UNH again as as UVM and UMass and UConn
have invested in these same types of
facilities this will be an attraction
and you know we can have a discussion
about in-state versus out-of-state
students we're about 50 50 but when you
think of 50 out of state 50 in state
when you think about that we're we're
like one of the number one attractors of
Young Talent into New Hampshire from out
of state as we try to keep our New
Hampshire students here as well so I
think it's incumbent upon all of us
collectively to do everything we can to
keep those students
working and staying and living here
after they graduate sorry if I that was
probably a lengthy too lengthy of a
response thank you
yes please thank you chairman a lot of
projects so explain the projects well
when we talk about hvacs and mechanical
and energy systems that we
are we doing some efficiencies in those
upgrades
um any Renewables geothermal stuff like
that by chance in in your effort
you want to take that yes so
um definitely looking at efficiencies as
part of these upgrades we have building
automation building automation system
that looks at the entire campus as well
where we would install controls in
individual buildings throughout campus
that then we can view as part of the
building automation systems to make sure
we're running it appropriately but as
far as renewals go Renewables go
UNH
we actually have our own co-generation
facility at UNH you may be aware of that
we bring in landfill gas from TurnKey
landfill we generate our own electricity
and heat as well we have a district
heating system across campus and that's
we we generate about 80 percent of the
electricity that we use through our own
through the landfill gas and
cogeneration and Heat's kind of a
byproduct of that of that process to
generate electricity that we then
distribute across campus in our district
heating system that heats many of the
facilities including the Whittemore yeah
all right thank you thank you any
I thank you so much for attending today
we will move to the Liquor Commission in
just wanted to follow up with the
committee to representative Jack's
question earlier around the um
appropriation
so the
University system appropriation was made
in 2019
but it wasn't going to be effective
until 24-25 so the number of the 113
number that representative Jack
mentioned you need to add the 17 to that
that would be the total new
Appropriations for 24 would be the 113
plus 17 which is a it's about 129
million in change is what you see I just
didn't want members to think that you
only had 113 budgeted and that you could
go to 120. that you you've already
exceeded the 120 with the UNH money and
the money that the governor has
thank you Mr Shea any questions of Mr
Shea what he just told us
that being the case I'm glad I asked the
question
thank you
that we could encumber in the future
yeah
we will now move on to the Liquor
Commission and um I want to welcome you
both being here today before us here in
public works thank you
if you could uh introduce yourselves and
um take us through your proposal
certainly thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee uh for the record I'm
Joseph Malik I'm the chairman of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission and with me
is our CFO Tina Demers we're here today
this morning to walk you through our
summer requests and Tina will do that
good morning chairman members of the
committee
uh on page two you'll see a summary of
our requests in the governor's capital
budget we have three requests the first
one is our Hampton North and South new
stores for 13.78 million the second is a
headquarters Life Safety Improvement for
2.4 million and the third is a roof
replacement at our Keen liquor store for
220 000. however we do have one other
project that was not included in the
governor's budget that we would like the
committee to consider consider
and that is 1.5 million for our computer
software upgrade called the 365 and I
will explain those on each of the coming
slides
so on the next slide number one is our
Hampton North and South new stores this
request is for additional funds
necessary to construct two new 20 to 22
000 square foot retail outlets on I-95
in Hampton
we originally requested 14 million uh
and that was all based on the FY 1819
budget the additional funds requested
here are based on current rates provided
by DPW
the current status of the project we
continue to work with our business
partners relative to existing title
issues in advance of issuing an RFP to
sell and develop the property most
recently we requested a change to the
Wetland delineation with des and then
working with the town of Hampton
Conservation Commission they hired a
wetland scientist to verify our
submitted plans and the town Wetland
scientists concurred with the commission
on March 1st in accordance with the
environmental
703.03 changes to the prime Wetland
boundaries Des accepted the revised
Prime Wetland
boundaries and now we're working with
our business partners on Covenant and
easement that is attached to the
property
so the additional time and expenses
resulting from The Unexpected due
diligence combined with the substantial
increases in building materials Fuel and
availability of construction related
labor has yielded escalations of all
aspects of the project financially in
very significant terms so we originally
requested about 7.5 million for the
project and DPW added
6.3 million to our estimates bringing
the total request to the 13.78 for a
total for the project of
27.78 million
I know that in the DPW estimates 3
million was for increases in cost but
there was also 3 million for inflation
okay our second project is our
headquarters Life Safety Improvement our
headquarters facility is 60 years old we
have some life safety and a small
renovation for office space that we're
requesting it's to replace Warehouse bay
doors 10 roll-up doors and connecting
them to the fire alarm because they
presently don't meet code and they were
noted in the Fire Marshal's annual
inspection we also have four exterior
Freight Bay roll-up doors that need to
be replaced replacing our building
security which is past its useful life
and is no longer supported
supplement for our FY 1819 appropriation
for our parking lot Rehabilitation since
the original funding we have found that
there are issues with the sewer line
catch basins infiltration system and
there's some infrastructure repairs that
need to be done under the parking lot
and then have it repaved so we're
requesting additional funds for that
and then a possible roof replacement for
the section of our roof that was
replaced in 2017
the roof was leaking when we put in our
original capital request but it has
since been repaired as part of the
warranty so at this point we're not sure
if it needs to be replaced or if the
patch is actually or the repair is
actually worked so with the unknown of
the roof replacement we're requesting to
add to this request a small renovation
for our office space we originally
requested this in our phase that was not
approved in the governor's budget
so in the event that funding is
available
without having to do the roof we'd like
to do a small 2200 square foot
renovation taking some of our warehouse
space for additional personnel and to
safely space out workstations
and that request is the 2.4 million
our third item is our Keen Outlet roof
replacement
um this was built the store was built in
2005 but it has been determined that the
roof was not properly installed uh it
leaks into the store and it needs to be
replaced the we found that it wasn't
prepared finished or sealed to the
industry standard and that request is
for 220 000.
and then the request that wasn't
included in the governor's budget is a
request for the d365 so we're in the
process of replacing all point of sale
software hardware and back office
computer systems
this funding would supplement for the
contracts related to the project and
possible enhancements or changes to the
system and additional equipment should
the needs a need arise after we go live
it would allow the commission to
implement enhancements that would
improve efficiency and increase Revenue
the d365 implementation requires
additional funds due to delays in
testing and this is caused by blackout
dates for liquor operations and the
state financials so the funding would
allow us
um to revise the contract with Accenture
who is the contractor doing the
implementation
for additional cut over support to
resolve integration issues to work with
Microsoft to resolve some persistent
software update issues and for
additional performance testing it's also
recommended that we conduct a
third-party security audit and the funds
will support that so in the agency
Capital Improvement request the
commission requested a million dollars
for an emergency fund and a million
dollars for this computer software
upgrade and we're at now asking for 1.5
million for this project and not asking
for the emerge agency funds
and those whoops yep those are all our
projects and we'll be happy to answer
thank you
um I'll ask first
so you're you're one and your one
million dollar request is from your
Enterprise fund the liquor funds or is
that from the state for general fund and
or bonding
um all of our requests are 100 liquor
funded beginning an Enterprise fund we
will fund all of the bonds
your thank you so your point of sale I
believe we've talked about that several
times for years and years
um
and um you just elaborate is is this an
upgrade to an upgrade or we had not
gotten to the point that you've expended
the funds for your point of sale just
give me a background please sure it's an
ongoing project the the system that the
Liquor Commission runs on now is called
mapper it's about 35 years old and it's
always been run it's an in-house program
it was designed and developed and
implemented by The Liquor Commission of
35 36 years ago so all the expenses
around running that program have been
in-house and what we're doing is
upgrading the system to a Microsoft
t365 system so it's more compatible with
the software and Hardware that's out
there today the system that we run on is
is a very obviously Antiquated system
and when we do a changeover like this
there's there's probably a reason it
hasn't been done for 35 years because
it's a massive undertaking you're
changing everything that the Liquor
Commission runs on so we are obviously
very cautious and very careful as we go
through this because it could affect
revenues and that's the last thing that
we want this change to do
thank you for the new members perhaps
you could explain
um when you have renovated stores or
built new stores
and I'm hoping this number stays there
that it usually equates to a higher
percentage of sales out of that property
could you could you address that for the
new members certainly well when we
renovate these these Pro these
properties obviously we've we've closed
a number of properties over the years
due to a number of reasons mainly
Staffing and stores that we considered
to be underperforming so as you've seen
over the last 10 years we've created a
brand we've created us an essential look
and feel for how we want this business
to look and we've taken that forward uh
in the last 12 years the prophet that we
see as we gain the square footage is
somewhere between 12 and 30 percent
depending on what store and and how we
do it even though we have less stores
today than we did originally when I'd
started at The Liquor Commission we have
12 or 13 Less stores we have about
300 260
000 additional square footage so we when
we when we
consolidate or build a new store we're
building it on a larger footprint for a
number of reasons first and foremost
50 percent of our business comes from
cross-border sales and in Massachusetts
in 2016 governor Patrick signed a bill
into law that allowed licensees in
Massachusetts to hold more than three
licenses and when he made that change
that attracted Total Wine and Spirits to
come to Massachusetts Total Wine and
Spirits is the largest liquor privately
owned liquor wholesaler a re I'm sorry
retailer of wine and spirits in the
United States they're in
27 States and they have 245 stores and
do about
about three and a half billion dollars
in business they have 11 000 employees
so since that time they have built six
stores in Massachusetts
uh understanding that the market was
woefully underserved there
they've put in six stores and they're
planning to build two more Costco is
planning to build another two in
Massachusetts this year BJ's is planning
to build another one store and Market
baskets as you may or may not know in
Maine and Massachusetts has gotten into
the liquor business in a business they
call MB spirits
so the competition that drives the
Liquor Commission to do what it does
every day is is based on what we see
happening across our borders and
protecting that 50 percent of sales that
uh representative Jack uh thank you MRN
uh if the chair will indulged me there's
a couple of different areas I want to
get into the first is uh if we were to
approve the item number four are we
confident that the liquor fund will
absorb the additional Debt Service it's
not clear to me why the governor didn't
include it
uh but yes we will we will be able to
fund it okay and uh second line of
questions
um
the um the scope of the headquarters
project seems to be a little bit
different
uh there's a lapse for
uh Concord headquarters roof replacement
and parking lot out of an abundance of
caution we may want to amend the purpose
on that so that it can cover this other
work that you want to do
yes
representative Newman
yes thank you
um
under your life safety improvements I I
have a question on the
section of roof that was replaced in
um
concerns about
how a design materials and installers
were selected if it failed and
and you had problems getting it taken
care of apparently there was no warranty
uh no the when representative it went
through an RFP process and the installer
during the time
since the installation has gone out of
business so we had some back and forth
with the manufacturer of the product and
they have agreed to send another one of
their licensed installers to do the
repair which has been done
and now we are just concerned that there
may be other areas that this original
installer that is now defunct may have
not done the right amount of work to or
done it properly so we're concerned that
there may be additional problems in that
area
aware of the rfps that were that were
done
do you are there people that oversee the
whole thing though so that
a company might go out of business but
the material used would have some
um
as you said the manufacturer took care
of of some part of it so going forward
how do you look to eliminate these
situations well uh Public Works oversees
all the commissions projects so
everything that we do construction wise
is overseen by uh whether it's a
building that we build like the Hampton
buildings or the Hooksett buildings or
the parking lot or the The Roof Is All
overseen by BPW so they kind of guide us
as to
where to go
and just just one last follow-up yes yes
and uh to the item about infrastructure
repairs under your parking lot
is that something are those something
different than running into catch basins
and curbing things
well uh
as the area of the parking lots have
failed there's a section of the parking
lot in front of the bay doors where the
tractor trailers roll over every day
there's some catch basins and drainage
there that DPW has found out have are
failing underneath the ground and we've
done a couple of uh
quick repairs there but that whole area
needs to be
excavated the pipes underneath replaced
so that's again it's 1965 that it was
done so it is failing
thank you Mr chairman
uh the question I have is on the
computer software uh on item four
um
does this money just cover the software
or does the current uh
sales equipment in the stores operate
off of this software because
or is that something that's going to
need to as a separate expenditure be
taken care of
kind of unclear
the the expenditure for the the hardware
pieces the the swipe cards the uh
computer systems the cash drawers that
money has been expended already and as
part of the project and those pieces of
equipment have been
filtered out into the stores as the old
pieces of equipment have been have have
failed so this is this additional money
that we're asking for
is just for
software implementation or upgrades in
the software and some additional as you
go through a project this this large you
get to a point where you say oh we this
is maybe something that we should have
looked at and should have done there's
an upgrade that's now available that
wasn't available when d365 first came
out and we're trying to take advantage
of those upgrades so when we do roll
this out to the stores we have that
system in place with all the uh
accoutrement that's available at that
time there's a there's a lot of things
that this system that we have now simply
cannot do uh discounting discounting in
the stores you may have noticed in some
of the stores now we have uh
electronic tags on the Shelf rather than
a paper tag so rather than those
employees having to print out tags every
month walk around the store and re-tag
we can now from a computer simply change
every single price at this at the drop
of a button so all those Savings in man
hours and paper and implementation are
now things that we can do electronically
Juan Paulo
now does this incorporate also the
servers that run all this large
operation across the state or has that
been
function with it also well the new
system the old system is servers that
are either at doit at Hazen or at the
Liquor Commission and the new system is
completely cloud-based so everything
will be done in the cloud
thank you representative Eaton
please just unfollow up on that I'm
assuming everything that's in the I.T
Spectrum goes through review Dennis
Gillette absolutely great we work hand
in hand he's actually on our executive
committee as is commissioner Bailey and
commissioner arlinghaus right and
going back to commissioner arlinghaus
the king store it's new in my mind my
turn my years
um
if somebody did not meet industry
standards do we have any recourse to go
back after that contractor and if not as
admin services and Public Works been
made aware that she had a contractor
that was operating substandard so that
we don't need to continue them to be
available in the future bidding
processes the answer is yes to both of
those representative thank you thank you
yes representative Juris thank you chair
the national location at exit 6 is it is
a lead certified building and I was put
up like what eight nine years ago and
I'm just curious with the new stores
will that type of construction go into
effect with any other kind of um
you know possibly heating type systems
like geothermal or photovoltaics you've
got a roof project going on too anything
like that in mind that that building is
one of the nine state-owned buildings
Representatives so we we don't own all
of our buildings but the one in Nashua
that's Lee gold certified is a
state-owned building a lot of the
buildings that we're doing now for
example in the new one in Nashua is a
Market Basket project the new one at
exit 17 is a is a privately owned
project so we and we have solar at the
project in in Concord we encourage the
landlords to do that but they're not our
properties they are they are leased
properties at this point
just a quick follow-up Chad yes thank
you so on the thank you for that and
in my neighborhood there was a location
closed at the 300 Main Street it's the
small store about maybe the size of this
this room
um are we is from your from your
presentation
for my recollection there's also a
similar size store in a Plaza on Danny
Webster maybe heading into Merrimack
it's it's near the Market Basket as well
uh that might be in Merrimack but uh are
those locations closing down and being
and and the local customers being asked
to to go to the to the bigger almost big
box type stores
well uh what we've done over the years
is try to represent the business as a
with a certain look and feel and a
certain brand and we certainly uh don't
want customers to come to a store that's
underwhelming and we certainly don't
want the customers to come to a store
that doesn't carry the plethora of
product that our competition carries so
we try to build these stores with what
we call a a 60 40 mix of wine and
spirits and around 11
000 skus so that's 11
000 different individual items that are
carried in the store we tend to see that
you need to have somewhere between nine
thousand and ten thousand square feet in
order to do that uh the the folks that
come from out of state when they shop
locally out of state they're shopping in
big box stores so I I think that our
mindset is to be able to
compete or compete and or exceed those
expectations when consumers come here
rather than being in the dog leg of a
Plaza in an old store that might only
have three or four thousands cues half
of what they'd expect in an old store
we're trying to upgrade these stores so
we have taken the stores
for let's just use Dairy for instance we
had taken the store away from dairy
itself downtown Dairy we opened a store
in Londonderry on exit four and at Exit
5. we have now gone back and addressed
the need for a store in Derry which will
be opening in April because we've been
able to find that nine or ten thousand
square foot Sweet Spot in order to build
that store so some of the stores that
have gone away have been Consolidated
with bigger stores and some of the
stores that have gone away will come
back with larger locations as we find
those locations
thank you thank you thank you thank you
yes please representative
thank you guys
um I see in your headquarters Life
Safety improvements
fire doors that don't meet code I I
would assume that they were built to
code at the time
so I guess
could I assume that there's not
grandfathering anymore
they were this was brought to our
attention by the fire marshal during an
inspection that these doors were no
longer up to code so they may have been
grandfathered for a certain period of
time but given that the building was
built in 65 these doors believe me look
to be original
and some of them don't work that's we're
just following with the with the what
they've asked us to do the fire marshal
has asked us to do
please uh Sun something else I see this
100 liquor funds
is that a like an account is that a
yes being an Enterprise fund we're
self-funded so our profits
um maintain our operations and our
overall profit is transferred to the
it's not retained there then no no okay
thank you thank you representative
Kaczynski uh I have one one further
question going back to the Hampton North
and South new stores
looks like the project uh had a
RFQ for 2021 but we're out to 2023 and
part of that delay was over a wetland
delineation correct and that you were
able to
um then I'm assuming instead of using
the Departments people with their
delineation you brought in another
expert and then everyone agreed that
that was sufficient that there might
have been some misalignment of that
mapping how how much of a delay did that
cost your project
Ballpark and money
did it delay your project by two years
and if I could follow up on that
when when you propose a new project that
goes through Public Works I would
imagine it does and Public Works is
accustomed to using Des to do the
mapping apparently we can have that
conversation after but
thank you thank you
seeing none
yes please Mike go ahead oh thank you Mr
chairman
um
yeah I'm from Hampton so some of this
interests me so I ask you a quick the uh
Delaney tried to build it on had certain
restrictions on it when you were
planning on building on it right and you
had to go through a process to
get things changed that's correct
representative yeah so I assumed it with
the the new delineations or whatever it
is if I could please please thank you
um that there are certain stipulations
there's going to be restrictions with
the when you go and put this out for bid
as far as what can be built and where it
can be built and absolutely there will
be and and the town is now in agreement
with the state and the Liquor Commission
as to the wetlands delineation there was
some acreage years ago when it was first
done that were considered Wetlands that
are no longer wet so we are we are now
in agreement and and have a letter from
the town as of last week stating as such
thank you
thank you representative thank you
um seeing no further questions thank you
so much for coming thank you very much
Mr chairman members of the committee
checks everything else
okay seems almost appropriate that we
would finish our morning with fish and
game ahead of lunch
and um I'm assuming Mr Mason
yes thank you sir would you please
present your fish and game proposal
uh good morning chairman
McConkey and committee members I'd like
to thank you for the opportunity present
our capital budget item today my name is
Scott Mason I'm the executive director
of New Hampshire Fish and Game
department
this year we have just one request for
355 thousand dollars to replace the roof
at our headquarters building
our headquarters roof has been leaking
for several years now it has come to the
end of its life
um we are at this point we are now
having damage to our ceiling tiles and
Carpeting and the insulation under the
roof liner has buckled and needs to be
replaced
um it's a pretty straightforward and I
do apologize
um although this is my second time
before capital budget committee my first
time we were in a zoom meeting structure
and um it's just hard to learn through
the zoom meeting so for all practical
purposes this is kind of my first trip
through and I apologize for not bringing
any written documentation
you're fine sir
yes represent me I guess my question is
has this been brought forward earlier
because
with what you're describing you're not
looking at just the damage you're
looking at possibility of mold and other
issues by having this protracted for so
long
um no this is the first time we've
brought this issue forward
um
I can only say that it's been leaking
for about two years I personally have no
knowledge beyond that as far as whether
it was leaking before or not I haven't
thank you further question
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question
um this is the item that you just
brought for us there's one of them
of several actually that you that were
on the list of things you were hoping
for do you want to speak to any of the
other issues here
um
the only one that I was prepared to
speak on was the one that was approved
by the governors as part of the
governor's capital budget
thank you
okay
so if I if I could sir so you're only
you're only bringing forward the one
project that's in the capital proposal
and
um your other items the Hatchery and
other items there
um you'd rather not elaborate at this
time well what I would like to do
um there was an item uh two years ago as
part of our capital budget item on the
hatcheries it was a 4.6 million dollar
capital budget item I believe it's uh
um and that was as I say it was for 4.6
million it was originally approved for
us to spend 4.6 million at just the
Powder Mill Hatchery and as that project
has developed the governor has expanded
it into looking at our entire system and
I would like to amend the work that you
folks did two years ago to allow us to
spend that 4.6 million on any of our
hatcheries where it's best suited to be
used
we're currently in a um we're doing an
engineering study of our complete
Hatchery system we haven't quite
finished it yet and unfortunately by the
time we get that finished and come up
with our plan uh this committee will be
done its work and and I'm
um preemptively asking for this even
though I don't necessarily have a plan
on spending it someplace else but I I
would like that flexibility as part of
our overall Hatchery development
um go ahead if I could thank you so um
item 99 uh you'd like to amend to
Statewide Fish Hatchery improvements
correct and the amount of money that you
have in that appropriation you think
will suffice
until we're done the actual finish with
a study I can't sit here and tell you
whether it will or it won't I can tell
you that the governor and
um has put
58.55 million in the Gopher funding for
us so this will push us over 60 million
dollars so at this time that's what our
ask is
um and we will as I say when we complete
the study we'll be able to have a much
harder figure
and and the other laps you have is
building security and fire safety
improvements and and we'll continue that
and that correct I know and I apologize
I um did not uh
um I wasn't able to research it before
today's hearing I know we've spent some
money out of that fund and I know
currently right now we are actively
looking at replacing the sprinkler
system at our new Hampton regional
office and also at our Durham Regional
Office the New Hampton regional office
we've done the main lines already and we
need to do the lateral lines and the
head at new in Durham we're going to
need to do the entire system well that's
not actually due until next week so okay
so you're fine on your deliverable
thank you yes please represent Bart uh
thank you uh I'm just curious why the
roof wouldn't know went through the
public works uh portion of the budget
allocation for
this the
because it's like 355
000 and my curiosity also falls under
will it get done this year or within the
next year and see
if Public Works does it does it fall
into the bucket requirements no the
buckets yes
I I I'm sorry Mr commissioner it's uh we
uh we've had discussion on the back on
how long a roof uh is leaking and how
many buckets it takes to contain that
leak and so I think that was a little
Insider on what we were well we're using
a trash can the trash can
so we'll Define it to TC or something
okay yes
yes thank you on the uh two hundred
thousand dollars
um for Hatchery infrastructure
improvements uh um it's written here
representative projects include
replacing failing septic systems well
pumps roofs so forth
this will re this request would allow
the department to respond in a in a more
timely manner
so my question is
if you've got a failing septic system at
what point
is it determined by
you that it is failed and if it fails
then what's the plan correct
um
our hatcheries have
not necessarily had the improvements
that they should have had over the
Capital Improvements they should have
had over the years
this last year we have lost several
Wells and also furnaces for whatever the
reason is on our furnaces and we are
fixing those out of the fishing game
fund and what we were what we're
originally trying to do was to seek
capital gains capital budget item to fix
that the governor suggested no
these are basically at this point
Band-Aids until we finish the plan and
decide exactly what you know where we're
going to raise fish and and to what
volume of fish we're raising at our
follow-up
for the fish I apologize the septic
system is for humans it's at the Berlin
Hatchery at this time it is functioning
but we do know that it is showing some
signs of
um
um not functioning properly but it
hasn't it has not failed
um
some of these this facility is an old
Federal facility uh uh I don't believe
we installed this we've had possession
of the facility since the 70s so we
really don't know how old that septic
system is but we do know it's a fairly
old
so
thank you
yes representative Newton yeah thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
it almost sounds to me like uh Powder
Mill is kind of taking a back seat
to the urgency we were told last session
to do the upgrades to what is the EPA
putting the hammer down a little more
because I know there's a problem with
the effluent going into the river which
eventually goes into Winnipesaukee but
Powder Mill is one of the biggest
hatcheries in the area and I'm
disappointed they've lost their salmon
fishery as a result of what's going on
there and I was led to believe that this
was going to all get better as they
improved the new powder Hatchery Mill
with new equipment that will be a lot
cleaner well what we're looking at is
the cost to come into compliance at
Powder Mill versus the cost of coming
into compliance in a different location
we may be looking at powder mill on a
much smaller scale than what it's
currently being run at and that is as I
say that is part of the long-term uh
project that we are still in the process
of researching and coming up with a plan
as far as the salmon those one of the
odd things we discovered was is that
when we raised salmon in other locations
such as the federal hatchery in
Nashville which is where we first raised
them and then last year where we raised
them at our new Hampton Hatchery the
water temperature was slightly warmer
and we had much better growth on our
salmon so we actually stocked a little
bigger salmon last year and the year
before coming out of those two
hatcheries
follow up Mr chairman yes please yeah um
where are you currently raising salmon
in New Hampshire that's not just the
federal uh New Hampton New Hampton thank
you
um thank you um I have just a question
so I I imagine fish and game has
multiple locations throughout the state
and I would believe from your testimony
that sometimes funding can be hard to
find and what gets replaced has fish and
game looked into possibly partnering
with as far as the septic systems are
concerned uh partnering with uh New
Hampshire
site evaluators who are always looking
for locations to test and bring people
to and to evaluate facilities and
perhaps you might be able to enlist them
to on a Statewide level over the course
of a couple years to look into that for
you
no we have not
if if you wouldn't mind I might put them
in touch with you yes at no cost and
they need continuing education hours and
so forth and I think I think it could be
of great benefit we'd offered that to
Department of Transportation they didn't
take that up in the past but I'll follow
up with you on that sir we um
facilities management is certainly a big
issue for our department and I think
that is an area that we can improve our
Management program on and my thought is
it might give you a long long range you
know where you are at this point in time
committee we are our next hearing is for
one o'clock
are there any other questions committee
maybe we could take at this point in
time while we have a few minutes
if not we will will recess till one
o'clock
okay
time being 103 will pull Public Works
back together here and we invite Frank
album commissioner and whomever you have
with you to join us please introduce
yourselves and
um welcome to uh Public Works
great for the record frankado Blue
Commissioner of Education
Tammy valencourt CFO for education
Jeffrey beard Deputy state director for
Career Technical education
good afternoon everyone
I have a three-page
presentation that I'm going to walk
through but then I have some other
handouts that I'll flag and there are
some unusual aspects associated with
this particular Hearing in that I'm
going to have conversation about capital
projects that are not in your capital
budget
and those are around some of the CTE
centers but I will start with the
purchase of 25 Hall Street which is the
current Granite State College building
for uh to give you a little bit of brief
history on Hall Street the Department of
Education was formerly located in the
laundry again building in the state
office complex
um about a year and a half ago we
started some work to renovate some
asbestos in our building we knew we had
asbestos in the flooring and
periodically if people were rolling
their chairs over that asbestos or
something else uh you know we had it
sealed up it would crack and it would
need to get resealed and so we would do
that
we were able to find some funding to be
able to permanently fix that by
replacing the floor so we didn't have
that exposure in the process of
remediating that asbestos the vendors
were in our office and they were
discussing the remediation of the
asbestos in the floor and they indicated
well what are you going to do about the
asbestos in the ceiling and so that was
information that we previously didn't
have and I can tell you that even
in my own tenure at the department we
had pulled cables in those ceilings we
had installed new
um you know Fire Systems in there so a
lot of stuff was happening there as a
result of that we realized that the
building
may not be appropriate for occupation at
that time and so we essentially
abandoned the building and we found we
located ourselves in other parts of the
state complex and worked remotely and so
what that meant was we doubled up and we
had some people who are working the
Tuesday Thursday in the office and
working remotely other days other people
who are working Mondays Wednesdays and
Fridays and they would come into the
office Tuesday Thursday so we basically
double upped our space we found some
space over at Health and Human Services
and we squeezed in in Johnson Hall but
really we kind of it was we dispersed
the organization we had one division
that was working fully remotely at that
point in time
um simultaneous to this and I think
somewhat fortuitously the university
system uh merged Granite State College
into UNH resulting in many of the
employees at the Granite State College
building into the UNH Manchester campus
and so they were leaving that building
and that building was available
so last January
we moved into that building so we had we
basically
um left Lonergan Hall about August of
22.
21 August of 21
um and then we moved into Granite State
22 yes got to get all my dates correct
you need to lose track
um and uh and so we have been there we
have had active and ongoing
conversations with the university system
they don't need the facility at 25 Hall
Street and so we because of that we're
leasing it from them right now
we made the proposal to procure that
building
as a facility it is
um more user friendly to the work that
we do for a couple of reasons one is and
this is a little known fact is we have a
number of unique visitors so we have
about 7 000 unique visitors unique
visitors per year uh to the Department
of Education these are in you know
mostly Educators coming in for licensure
issues or other types of training issues
that they have we also conduct a high
number of trainings in our facility at
the Granite State College building there
are several classroom facilities that
enable our ability to host those at the
facility rather than to locate outside
facilities for the various trainings and
stuff that we do and so it is a a
facility that is conducive to the work
that we do at the department so we
initially submitted a capital budget
request for seven million dollars which
at the time was the estimate that Kathy
provencher and myself we worked with
their capital team at the UNH and
determined that seven million dollars
would be a good place holder in terms of
trying to understand what the value
would be that is what we submitted in
our agency budget that was increased in
the budgeting process through a Das
process increasing that to 10.5 million
dollars as the capital item and so that
is where we stand right now we are
leasing that facility from the
University system
without that facility we don't have we
presently don't have a home the Lonergan
hall building
is currently being worked on by the
department of administrative services to
be refurbished and there's an estimate
probably around and my guess is around
two years to be able to fully refurbish
that facility one of the advantages in a
conversation I've had with Charlie
arlinghaus relative to this is you know
if that facility is refurbished and
becomes occupiable again then
it's likely that there are other
agencies that would need would probably
move in there likely from HHS they would
occupy that facility and we would remain
where we are but again it really depends
on what the legislature wants to do
relative to this particular building if
they want to acquire this building or
not if we don't acquire this building we
don't have another place that we would
go as an agency and we would obviously
then have to seek some type of lease
space or some other type of space for
the agency
so that is the first project and I will
take questions on that and then I'm
going to introduce two other projects to
you
thank you Mr Adler the
so I I guess maybe
so we had appropriated monies when you
were in the last capital budget because
your the state of your bathrooms over in
that building
um were those are those Renovations and
I think we've had some conversations
since that those Renovations where they
put in place or is that money on hold
they were not put in place at this point
in time
that is part of the overall project that
Das will be working on in renovating the
entire building it includes those
bathrooms and the funds for those
bathrooms so is is that money showing up
as as a lapse
an extension yes we've requested an
extension yes but but the problem is now
they're in the wrong agency
if Das is doing the work
the funds you're appropriated are in the
wrong agency
um Das has always done the work so even
though they were in our agency Das was
doing the work and we were just going to
encumber those funds so basically Das
would give us the information we would
all right let's representative
um
so my question I'll come back to my
did I hear commissioner when you were
speaking and you were getting through
those projects and you had the broken
tiles and Asbestos and issues and so
forth did I hear you say then when
you've got someone said what are you
doing about the uh
the ceilings and we've done extensive
work over there over the years I would
imagine and that's just now coming to
light
should I speak to Public Works about
that so that would be a question for
public works I think that there was a
2000 and when did they have that study
yeah so it's about like 2007 2009 there
was a study um unfortunately none of
those
uh you know areas of asbestos have been
marked as such okay in your new building
the um the Hall Street Building and I
appreciate the multiple times we've
tried to arrange going over there which
we will
um so is is there even more Office Space
over there that's available than you're
moving into or or your needs going to
fill that entire building so it would be
depend on what the committee wants to do
but we fill most of the building right
now there's a small section that is
continuing to be occupied by Granite
State College and on the in the basement
floor there's a small section that is
occupied by third party lessees at this
point in time okay but otherwise we've
moved into the you know the totality of
the building if we were to further
consolidate you know if those two spaces
became available to us we would try to
initially move our career in technical
education which is in the Walker
building over as well as our adult
education programming
and then at that point you would be
fully occupied correct okay thank you
questions for the commissioner on this
before we move on
yes please representative
thank you um how old is this building
I don't know the answer to it I do know
that it was complete it was fully
refurbished by the university system
yeah
we've been hearing
about many government buildings when
they hit
50 years or 40 years they're obsolete so
I would hate to get into something like
that
something like you know purchasing
something like that if that's gonna
something we'll have to deal with in the
future yes so I can tell you that you
know in our current occupancy of the
building it has been fully refurbished
already so um like in other words like
when we moved in there it was literally
a move-in condition when the university
system left they left their Furniture I
mean it was totally as is we just moved
ourselves in including furnished
thank you
further questions yes representative
thank you chairman uh commissioner oh go
ahead but we can get the date of the the
purchase or the date of the construction
of that building
19.
1987.
are you all set represented
yeah I just want to ask one okay please
go ahead one follow-up
um yeah so that building is asbestos
free then as far as We Know
okay
I I'm I'm sure that's going to be
assessed so we have that answer yes
thank you that was going to be my
question Shannon okay thank you further
questions
I will say we've had a
I I'll come right back to you uh we have
had a conversation on that 10.5 million
and there's another number floating out
there the seven yes yes so seven is what
we had initially estimated and that was
a number that was derived with uh Kathy
provenchar who is the vice Chancellor
over at the University system and their
Capital folks and myself
um and then subsequently when we
submitted that the department of
administrative Services increased that
number from 7 to 10.5 thank you sir
um yes representative vallone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
commissioner for taking my question what
is the square footage of Lonergan
people
approximately fifty thousand so so you
thank you any further questions for
commissioner elbow
yes please representative uh thank you
Mr chairman and thanks for the answer to
this
um I assume that you've done somebody's
done a complete inspection of the
building everything HVAC and everything
and there's nothing else that has to be
fixed or is this the 10.5 include any
upgrades or something you might have to
do so that it has not yet been inspected
excuse me
um so we assume that and through the
procurement process and Department of
administrative Services is here to
address any questions through the
procurement process the initial step is
really to be able to get approval to
move forward and then we will do that
can I have a funnel okay thank you
when is this assessment going to be
completed is it going to be completed in
time for us during our review of the
capital budget
elect Department of administrative
good afternoon thank you Karen rantamaki
with Department of administrative
services for the record
um so we're as part of the purchase
process we would undergo you know what I
like to call a home Home Inspection just
um to use a term that that people are
familiar with
um we're currently doing one over at uh
Granite place prior to you know
purchasing that building if that was to
get approved so we will initiate the
same process here and it will take about
a month so
um we can move forward with that you
know as soon as as soon as it makes
sense to okay thank you further question
seeing none do you want to move on on
your presentation I'd be happy to do
that so then I would also like to flag
for the committee to CTE centers that we
have initially submitted in our Capital
request
these were both submitted as the agency
through the capital process in the
governor's phase of the budget
the
capital projects associated with the CTE
Center rebuilds were moved out of the
capital budget into the education trust
fund and one of those CTE centers was
dropped out of that funding proposal I
don't know if it's you know we can we
can do this if you want if you have time
Jeff is here to kind of address some of
the highlights associated with our CTE
centers I'm not sure how familiar
members of this committee are with what
our CTE education is and what it does
for the state and for the students of
New Hampshire is that valuable for you I
if if we could contain that into a USA
Edition article I'd really I'd really
appreciate it it'd be helpful for the
members
gladly thank you
um so if I could direct everyone to page
five of the the handout that was
provided that the cover of it is uh has
the Bureau of career development logo
the uh one very important thing about
Career Technical Ed is that it's a
really powerful economic driver for the
State of New Hampshire if you think that
each uh CTE program has the potential to
graduate between 10 and 20 students per
year and there are as you can see here
some projected growth of about 10 000
jobs across the state that's one year's
growth and that's a fairly consistent
Trend that we've been seeing since the
recovery from uh from covid that means
that each region has the potential to
provide a powerful pipeline of trained
and knowledgeable employees for
Employers in their area
the the other piece of that is the time
to actually enter the workforce is uh is
relatively quick there are some of our
programs that are more trades focused
for example a young person after two
years of entering a CTE program is ready
to enter the workforce when there's a
little bit more Education and Training
needed it's between two and four years
to enter the workforce so it's a fairly
quick turnaround time to respond to the
needs of employers
the other
um piece and then the next two slides
are a little bit of testimony given by
Employers in the state but I did want to
direct everyone to page
nine of the handout and just give a
little historical context of the CTE
projects in the past
so as you can see the the current two
projects are highlighted on that table
the budgets for each is fairly in line
with what has been funded previously you
can see uh over the time captured on
this table that construction costs have
increased but overall these projects are
are in line with what has been funded in
previous uh budgets
the the two projects that are utter
consideration are Newport and win a
squab let's go for one second and just
see if the question is generally about I
just you know that's kind of a highlight
of CTE uh the program serves about 9500
students across the state both in
ascending and receiving districts again
students enter into those programs as
early as 10th grade they generally spend
two years students that come out of
there earn an industry recognize
credential for their participation in
that program so these are students who
are already credentialed exiting high
school at that point in time in their
thank you so then let me let me just
flag for you the two projects if I may
so the two projects that we have before
you are the uh Sugar River RTC Center in
Newport this is a renovation for 12
million 500 000 approximately
um
and uh is a project that and and one of
the things that that Jeff was pointing
out is that these projects have been in
the queue for a number of years for
decades actually
um and we generally fund about two of
them each year
and that particular project has a
community a vote already approving and
authorizing the local match associated
with it so they are literally shovel
ready uh the architect is here today and
he can tell you that when this project
is approved we are ready to begin
construction on July 1. uh there are the
bid process has already begun we've got
contractors bidding on this work now
the second project is a project in
winnisquam this is a project that has
been on the books for some amount of
times it's uh 7.6 million dollars and
again they have been waiting and working
in their Community to try and get uh you
know the approval for this project
they've done all the architecture
they are anticipating going to their
voters this month to get approval I will
point out that they went to their voters
previously and they were within 10 votes
of getting approval so there is some
degree of confidence that this will be
more successful
in terms of getting approval because it
was not already approved by the the
voters in the community it was not able
it was not included in the governor's uh
you know funding for the CTE Center
Renovations
um
in and even if we you know we take that
into consideration so we'll go to voting
later this month I believe it's on uh
March 25th if it doesn't uh get approval
then it won't go forward obviously but
we are encouraging uh you know the
ability to try and do this project it is
an important project in the community
it's an important project for our
education system in terms of making sure
that students in that particular region
have the ability to partake in some of
these Career and Technical education
advancements in both cases
um you know the the conversation and in
the governor's budget he took it out of
the capital budget which I guess is a
good for you found money and capital
committee right and has been moved over
to
um the education trust fund so I only
bring that to your attention because
while the governor has funded 12.5
million dollars for the Sugar Valley in
the education trust fund it is possible
if this committee decides that they want
to do that to be able to fund uh the win
a Squam project in the capital budget if
that's if you see fit to do that
and we and I will point out that we have
representatives from both of the schools
here if there are specific questions
that the committee might have for those
communities who are working on those
projects including the architect for
both projects
I will um just say that over my 20-year
that I've been around this committee
it's always been a high very high
priority for this committee to make sure
that we do everything we can to get to
schools into the cycle we've fallen
short at times we've had Governors tell
us we couldn't fund any but we have
always made sure that we at least were
able to upgrade one the issue is if you
only upgrade one then it's a cycle
backwards and instead of getting our
schools brought up to standard every 20
years it just it just delays the process
and needless to say the cost is more are
there questions yes representative yes
uh just to piggyback on what he said in
the past we have for instance your your
seven and a half million dollars for
when a Squam but it hasn't been voted on
yet in the past we've always asked that
if we devote this money and you don't
and they can't come through with the
matching thing rather than just let the
money go to waste do you have somebody
in queue that can step in and take that
money if we appropriate it yes uh uh
conval Region 14 is uh needs to do their
preliminary planning but they are ready
and they have a uh they're prepared to
have a vote uh in hand so they would be
they would be next in line and would be
prepared
we have some idea what what their need
would be in millions
that I don't know uh off the top I had
to be honest that's all right if you can
get back to us on that if um is so this
seven can you just address I know we
don't have an awful lot of time do you
do you have details here on win a Squam
and kind of tell us can someone tell us
what the scope of what it is you're
trying to do or a new program
enhancement at winners Squam Newport is
already in there and I don't suspect
we have a lot of conversation about that
or we can get back to you on that sure
and there is a presentation that we
handed out to you on the when a Squam
project so that you'll have all of the
details about the program
and I'm happy if somebody from the
community wants to come up and share
with you what their objectives are would
that be appropriate that would be
ly
hello I'm Shannon Bartlett I'm the
superintendent of the one of Squam
Regional School District
I'm new this year to win a Squam so I I
came in after the first vote for this
project but we've worked extensively
this year to gather more support from
our community members what we plan to do
is double the footprint of the building
so that we can renovate the spaces that
currently exist for our two AG programs
our natural resources and plant and
animal science and then the increased
space would be for adding the
cosmetology program and a Precision
I'm sorry so you you would add two new
programs and those one was cosmetology
and what was the other one Precision
manufacturing which means what it is if
you think about end
and as as one
engineering background Precision
manufacturing is the actual
um
cutting of machine shops yeah so what
they basically yeah they're teaching
students how to machine they'll use CNC
machines and teach them how to cut parts
for you know Precision Machining thank
you thank you so are you in in if this
was able to move forward are you
partnering with anyone on this the
cosmetology do you have
Paul yeah you know can you tell me about
that that's we're working with Empire
Beauty School which is local in Laconia
on the cosmetology end and several local
businesses are supportive of this and
then for precision manufacturing eptam
3M freudenberg STS Aerospace we have
several different
businesses locally that are partnering
with us and we'll if I could will any of
those bring lab labs in for you to train
your train your students so that when
they come out like I believe you have
over there your your air conditioning
program and others and some of the
schools have Auto Labs is anybody coming
in to help you provide part of your lab
work
well we're hoping to have work with
these companies for equipment donations
but then we will staff our programs with
you know experts in the fields people
fields and and if I may um work based
learning is a requirement of every CTE
program in the state of New Hampshire so
there's a component where whether it's
students going out to do internships in
the community with employers or
employers coming in it's part of our
federal accountability reporting we
receive about six million dollars in
federal funding each year for Career
Technical education programs it's one of
our accountability metrics but it's also
a requirement in order to be an approved
CT program in New Hampshire and to
maintain that approval for the program
you must have a work-based learning
component which is exactly what uh was
just described and as well each of these
programs has a industry Advisory Group
which is made up of the industries in
that sector and in that area that works
very closely with the students with the
schools to make sure that you know if
we're training them on using a certain
CNC machine it's the stuff that our
Industries need it's not just what we
decide that they want and you're animal
and plant science program and natural
res are those well students wanting to
go in there Yes actually our enrollment
has just climbed over the last five or
six years so and I think there's a chart
in there that shows that enrollment
right I mean this is also one of the
areas that we see as a growth industry
in the state is around the plant science
in particular where you have these large
Greenhouse operations that are coming
into the state and you need individuals
who are well versed in the science
associated with that type of an
agricultural industry and and obviously
very unique to the cold climate like a
New Hampshire
questions
yes representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman and I thank you for taking my
question do I understand that the the AG
Center is part of the CTE or it's a
separate separate uh
effort
it is part of our our building right now
is is just for agriculture so we would
be adding to it and becoming a regional
CTE Center
another question
yes representative
my question has to do with the the first
CET that was mentioned so I don't know
if I want to hold it or if I want
okay
um the basically 12 and a half million
uh that's gonna I guess go before the
finance committee
um and it's going to come out of
Education trust funds so they you just
paint it out right from there or you're
going to be bonding it from there or
no that would come that would be a
direct funding through the education
trust fund
but not bonded oh direct payment okay
correct very good thank you thank you
okay
all right I I believe you've answered my
the local businesses that are supporting
this operation from what I'm looking at
the list they seem to all be within
Belknap County so that would help
with the Machining processes and stuff
like that that's a big
business within Belknap County itself as
far as adding uh a labor force that is
lacking at the moment because if one
would look in the newspaper it seems
there's always
a large amount of requests for help in
the Machining aspect of that business is
that true that is true we actually did
at one of our events was a panel
discussion where we brought in people
from business Managers from these
businesses and they talked about their
desperate need for employees and how
much they would welcome these programs
and offer internships and experiences to
get students in the door so they were
really excited about it and another
aspect is for every program that's
approved we go through kind of using
jobs EQ data to make sure that there are
a sufficient number of job opportunities
at an appropriate wage for individuals
in these communities to be able to
succeed
if and it's an if if
the committee were to come up and make
policy decision that they wanted to move
forward with the two schools
in this 7.6 million dollars
is are you confident this money could be
spent in in this time to have this
happen or is this a project if we could
find you four million to start in
so let me just clarify the question
because we've done this in the past
we've split CTE centers over a biennium
I don't know that I know the answer to
that
yeah it probably has to happen nobody
anymore and part I mean in in Lance is
here and we can have him describe that
in particular but one of the issues
might be uh costs associated with
building as you know there's been
leading up to this point in time there's
been a significant amount of inflation
in the project so if you as we delay the
costs generally are going up at this
point in time so it may not be a good
candidate for a split thank you
um I think we're fine here do you have
something else to present at this time
no that would be everything thank you
all right
certainly appreciate your time and thank
you great if the committee has any other
questions we're happy to come back thank
you
for the Department of energy uh why
don't you come on forward while we're
passing out some information
Department of energy welcome to Public
Works
some faces I recognize you just please
introduce yourselves and tell us what
you're asking for in the capital budget
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Chris Elms I'm the
Deputy Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy and I'm joined by
Josh Elliott who is the director of our
division of policy and programs
among the varied responsibilities of the
Department of energy are a number of
assistance programs that we administer
this includes the federally funded
low-income home energy assistance
program LIHEAP which funds what we call
the fuel assistance program that program
provides fuel assistance to eligible
households who are 60 percent or under
State median income we also administer
the federal weatherization assistance
program which similarly provides
weatherization services to households
that are 60 percent of State median
income or below
both of these programs are administered
by the department and we contract out
with the local Community Action agencies
for the on the ground work
um you know working with applicants
processing those applications and
getting payment out behind all of that
is a software system that tracks and
manages
basically the whole assistance process
from eligibility determinations to
benefit determinations all the way
through payment and then the federal
compliance reporting
um the software has passed its useful
life and this federally funded capital
budget proposal will provide better
service to the people of New Hampshire
if it is approved and able to move
forward I'm going to turn it over to
Josh who's going to talk a little bit
about the specific problems we're
dealing with and and the potential
solution thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee as the Deputy Commissioner
mentioned I am Josh Elliott director of
the division of policy and programs
um again the two programs we're talking
about today the weatherization
assistance program as well as the fuel
assistance program fall within uh this
division
so there's three real main reasons that
we're asking for this capital budget
request first is the Deputy Commissioner
alluded to the current software is
roughly 20 years old is obsolete in his
risk of failing it's a very fragile
system as currently exists and also it
can't uh it can no longer keep up with
the increased federal reporting
requirements weatherization assistance
program the fuel assistance program are
both 100 federally funded as is this
request it is 100 federal funds lastly
it'll increase efficiencies both of the
Community Action agencies as well as the
department of energy itself in terms of
managing these programs which will
result in Greater service to the people
of the State of New Hampshire so as the
Deputy Commissioner mentioned did some
discussion about what exactly the
software is and what it does it really
is the backbone of this system it takes
manages everything from the intake
process all the way through to the
federal reporting on the opposite end in
every single step in between
so to give you a sense of scale the fuel
assistance program has roughly 24 000
clients or households that it serves
every year WAP is smaller usually serves
between 300 and 400 households per year
the system itself actually intakes more
than that so if you think there's folks
who apply who are then denied assistance
usually it's over income so the total
number is usually closer to 30 000 every
year
um
so with this with this old Software
System again it's about 20 years old
it's limping along at this point
um with uh aging software there's always
an increased risk of failure or uh or
other sort of
um issues that might happen that'll
potentially stop the the software in its
tracks essentially if there were if
there were any sort of failure with the
system would be catastrophic for the
assistance program so you can imagine
trying to do all these things manually
you wouldn't have the amount of staff to
actually be able to do it you need the
software system to do a lot of that
heavy lifting
uh second uh as we as I mentioned the
federal reporting requirements again
these are 100 federal funds
um as time has gone on the federal
reporting requirements have increased
year over year over year
um resulting in uh in increased workload
both at the Community Action Agency
level as well as the department of
energy to make sure that we are filing
those reports and the correct
information is in it we've heard from
colleagues in other states of uh you
know their Data Systems they're able to
push a button and they get the data that
they may need out for a report
unfortunately for us it can take up to a
week working with our software folks to
actually be able to get the data pulled
that we need to complete these required
Federal reports
um thankfully with these newer software
systems it's literally a push of a
button I'm probably grossly
oversimplifying it but essentially it's
it's much easier than the current system
and lastly there's increased efficiency
and functionality
um with more efficient software that
frees up additional time especially the
Community Action Agency level to be
processing applications working with
clients talking to folks about other
programs they may be eligible for and
then of course the department of energy
you get increased efficiencies in terms
of okay if you're not waiting a week to
get data pulled you can get those
reports compiled faster we can dedicate
more time to managing the program making
sure that every dollar is spent in a an
appropriate and and efficient way
um so
with that
um I will say that uh thankfully every
other state in the Union has similar
programs weatherization fuel assistance
programs
um so software there are a number of
vendors who create and build software
specifically for these two programs and
they need the interactions that happen
in between them so it is a fairly
off-the-shelf product that can be
acquired from a variety of vendors which
will hopefully reduce some of course
some customization will be needed but
it'll dramatically reduce
um it's not a long lead time we're not
custom building software we're not doing
anything more complex it's a fairly off
the shelf product which will cut down an
implementation time as well as cost so
with that I will conclude and happy to
take any questions the committee may
have thank you gentlemen my my first
question so it's 100 Federal there's
there's no State match here in in this
funding that is correct and when you
talk to your colleagues throughout the
country where is this is every state
getting this amount of money to
typically or where do we fall when we
get our our Highway money coming back to
us New Hampshire falls right at that
bottom have you had any conversations to
see where we are does every state
depending on scale get something near
this amount
um it will depend on the state there's
actually for for a lie Heap itself or
fuel assistance program it is a very
complex formula that's determined by U.S
Department of Health and Human Services
there are cold weather States versus
warm weather States
um as it also does for uh electric
assistance for folks for example if
you're in Florida you really don't need
heating but you know electric uh benefit
to reduce how much it costs to air
condition your home obviously makes a
difference
and there's a sort of a complex waiting
formula I can't say off the top of my
head if we get more or less based on
that but being a cold weather State I
would think we would probably tend to
lean a little bit more than we would
other states
thank you questions yes representative
Jack thank you Mr chairman and thank you
it's good to see you again let me ask
the question a slightly different way uh
is there some risk that if you these
apparently are not funds that you can
just go and say we need these and you
get them you have to there has there's
some allocation going on and there's a
um this would come out of our regular
allocation of federal LIHEAP or federal
fuel assistance or federal
weatherization funds um it's allowable
use for these funds um so we know we
have the money we have it here there's
no there's no risk of that we would then
expend these and then be coming back
which if I could conclude you the train
of thought we wouldn't be asking the
general fund to make up the difference
okay thank you further questions
yes please representative Newton thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question could you give me a snapshot of
say the last five years with this
program is it just plugging along at
about the same percentage of numbers or
are you seeing a major uptick or if you
could answer that it might be an unfair
question to ask you I'm not sure sure so
for this year it gets a little bit
complicated um and I can't recall if you
were if this is your first term or if
you've been if you've been a
representative for a while
um however um you may recall that um
House Bill 2023 passed last year that
required the department to set up these
additional assistance the state
assistance emergency assistance programs
that were using the same system so a lot
of times the at the um the applications
all go through the same process so we've
seen higher enrollment numbers this year
because we're we see both both programs
both happening simultaneously within the
same system if you look over the last
five years or so sort of taking that
anonymous out
um enrollment in these programs
weatherization less so that tends to be
more pretty much pretty standard
fuel assistance really depends on how
the larger economy is doing being that
it's tied to median State median income
um during times of when there's higher
unemployment we see higher numbers of
enrollment if you see better Economic
Times you see decline in enrollments but
on average for the last couple of years
we've been going right around 24 000
households who have been served we
expect you know probably once all the
dust settles between the new
um uh with the new emergency assistance
programs we expect that number to be a
little bit higher especially with the
increase in fuel costs more folks
there's really a great sense of Yankee
frugality in this day where folks don't
want to necessarily take the help but a
lot of times you know when they see
increased fuel prices they're a little
more willing to come into to get this
benefit
thank you again why don't I ask one more
question relating to your lapse
extension since we have a few minutes uh
it starts out in 17 and it's been
extended since then uh and I thought I
heard understood you to say now there's
an off-the-shelf thing you can get so
what have we been doing since 2017 on
this project
sure thank you for the question
um I will say I just started with the
Department in 2021 so I don't have I've
got a sort of a sense of the
institutional Knowledge from folks
who've been around
um in 2017 was the original
um uh request for the 316 000 again all
100 federal funds uh there was of course
a change in administration you moved
from uh Governor had now Senate U.S
senator Hassan's Administration to the
sununu administration you have a
changeover in staff of the former office
of strategic initiatives
um work had begun to progress on uh
working through that so there was the
extension in 2019 to allow that uh
drafting of that RFP to continue uh the
former OSI had issued a
um an RFI request for information for
this software as well as an RFP for a
consultant to assist with drafting the
RFP for this software and then of course
uh covet hits a lot of the staff from
OSI were then detailed to assist with
with gopher
as those emergency programs were getting
stood up with the the influx of federal
funds then of course you have the
creation of the department followed by
the emergency assistance programs the
department stood up last summer so you
can sort of see there's sort of been a
series of of obstacles
um uh sort of outside of the
Department's control to
um
to be able to sort of move forward on
this software project I am though I am
happy to say we are well into the uh
developing the uh scope scoping of the
various criteria that are needed for
each of these various programs actually
before coming over here I just had a
meeting with our folks on the
weatherization side to see how well that
was going
um we're progressing along and we're
going to be reaching out to the
Community Action agencies which will be
our next step to talk to them about what
thank you chairman you mentioned that
the software packages are caught it's
commercially available off the shelf
is that more than one developer for
these types of programs and I'm guessing
they do a little more than just around
the country than just energy or uh fuel
assistance Etc so you'll be will you be
bidding or will this be a sole source oh
no we expect this to be competitively
bid um there are a number of companies I
can I believe there are at least three
off the top of my head
um but as you mentioned a lot of states
will use these across their uh HHS
various
um uh uh assistance programs so there's
a lot of sort of the same infrastructure
but for the for New Hampshire we're
looking at using it just for these these
two programs and just just three
follow-up uh so any upgrades
um any software patches will be easily
uh downloaded or obtained or obtained uh
going forward I would guess yes so there
would probably be some sort of service
contract that would go along with this I
don't know thank you thank you yes uh
representative balone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so how do you get to 884 thousand
dollars
um so this is something we we actually
did a survey of a couple of different
um vendors to say here's what we're
looking at just sort of in Broad broad
terms of the kind of software we're
looking at
um and this was sort of a rough average
of the quotes that came back from
vendors of this who provide these kinds
of services
may I follow
thank you follow up please represent
okay so how do you break that down
so you just went to a vendor and they
just said 884 I'm sorry I'm just at this
I'm used to getting a little more
information about how that builds up to
880 so one part uh consultation is it
uh yes so this is just for example of
one of the software companies um that we
have uh that we reached out to when we
were doing this initial uh request for
information again this was from April of
last year so these numbers will probably
need to be updated at some point and I'm
sure we'll probably talk to your Senate
colleagues about uh about potentially
um if there have been any increases
since then to get a better number
um but for our implementation and
Licensing of fully configured software
out of the box 650 000 optimization
customizations or external interfaces
another 150 000 and then there's a
monthly software maintenance and support
and hosting fees that go along in
addition to that
just about seven thousand dollars a
month
uh yeah so that would that would be
thirty thousand dollars so again that
would be broken up over the over the
course of a year yeah thank you you're
welcome
seeing none thank you gentlemen
appreciate it thank you thank you
foreign
can you hear me now sorry about that I'm
still not used to this mic so bear with
me and if you could please introduce
good afternoon my name is Lori Weaver I
am the interim commissioner for the
good afternoon my name is Nathan white
I'm the Chief Financial Officer for the
thank you for having us here today we
have a brief presentation for our two
approved capital
projects
my water bottle is not going to stand up
so I have a team I have Nathan here I
have our facilities director and our
Information Services director so I will
get us started and give you an overview
and then I will turn it over to go
through the detailed requests and then
take questions
um for those of you thank you please
proceed
thank you but for those of you that may
not be familiar with the Department the
first slide is our mission statement
basically why we exist in um and who
we're serving and it's really about our
population uh most vulnerable population
in New Hampshire so it's about health
needs human needs and protection and
there's a some sentences here in terms
of describing all of it but basically
we're responsible for ensuring that our
most vulnerable population has served if
you flip to the next slide
slide 3 is a way to sort of chunk out
the department I'm sure you've heard
that the department is the largest state
agency what exactly do we do we do a lot
of different work we do have Direct
Services delivery to clients which is
that first bullet we have 11 district
offices throughout our state where we
have our staff engaging with the public
via case management and client services
but we also have direct care which is
that third bullet and I will just bring
to your attention there is a error here
if you could just so note that our
Direct Services include New Hampshire
hospital glencliffe home the designated
receiving facility listed is no longer
you can cross that off that was in
Laconia and we sold that property and we
closed that program two years ago you
can replace it with Hampstead Hospital
Residential Treatment Facility Center
which is the state bought Hampstead
Hospital a year ago
and currently have that property we have
the sununu Youth Services Center and we
also have what you may hear as path
p-a-t-h which is our Philbrook adult
transitional housing program so through
those five uh locations we actually
service clients and we're responsible
for the property
and all that comes with it so it's not
just client delivery it's also the
logistics on the property we're all
about protection so there's adult
protection and Child Protection the
department does regulatory oversight so
we are responsible for licensing CMS
facilities Health Facilities child care
facilities and so on we do a lot of
Education through our public and
providers on our systems of care as well
as public health services and obviously
ensuring program and operational
Integrity so that is probably the
most Cliff note version of what the
department does there's obviously a lot
more to it but in in the context of
capital budget we have submitted for
this year
um
numerous project requests and were
granted two in the governor's budget
which we are here to speak about today
which is our dcyfc West which is our
child welfare information system Bridges
modernization and electronic health
records
so if there aren't any further questions
I could turn it over to our Information
Services director Dave Wieters please do
good after
sorry good afternoon my name is David
Wieters Information Services director
for Health and Human Services thank you
chairman and members of the committee
for
for having me here and I'm going to
speak to you about a couple I.T capital
projects that you may have already heard
about about a week and a half ago from
commissioner Goulet on his presentation
so hopefully not duplicating too much
but the first one on slide four is the
Child Welfare information the
comprehensive child welfare information
system so this this particular Capital
project is the third time that we're
coming for capital for essentially a
six-year program so we've had two other
capital projects that we went for in
previous bienniums that support this
six-year transition to a modernized
system
it's replacing a 23 year old system that
was written in a power Builder which is
an older programming language that
really isn't supported anymore and we're
having difficulty hiring new staff to
support and with the goal of modernizing
that system to not only enable the
caseworkers to work in the field but
make them more productive in the sense
of having self-service functionality
having access to the information when
they're in the field with the the
families and the children so that they
um they don't have to come back to the
office to get information printed out go
back out in the field some of the
modernizations over the last two decades
have enabled those kind of functions and
we're looking to upgrade that this
particular system or project for this
next two bienniums is for 11 million 270
800 and will be fifty percent federal
funds and 50 General funds we partner
with the administration for children and
families for that Federal funding
and throughout this process have been
continuing to provide them reports and
updates as we move along
the key improvements that we that I sort
of addressed but it directly will
provide that automated system for 700
workers and supporting over 5 800 cases
per year
as well as a total of 45 000 people
served over over the duration so this
replacement will really enable us to
move that forward address
um current manual on processing as well
as legislatively align with our Federal
Acts that are requiring us to implement
this comprehensive Toronto well Fair
information system
with that I'm going to move to the next
one unless there's any questions on the
yes thank you I'm not sure if I heard
you correctly did you say that you were
there was something about a staffing
issue
thank you for the question
representative Newman
um day Staffing challenge was supporting
the Legacy software and the way it was
developed was in an old technology so
maintaining the resources to support
that is difficult you may another
reference is like a Mainframe
programming Mainframe programmers are
hard to come by and so we're trying to
essentially just like you do with
buildings and Roads you have a useful
life for I.T systems and that system is
normally about seven to ten years we're
at 23 years and so people that can
actually support that system are few and
far between whereas the new modern
technology it's easier to find people to
support develop and design those
Solutions as well as maintain them
thank you thank you uh represent Boger
so you indicated it was 50 percent
funded so I can understand this
being as simple than I am does that mean
this whole program's 22 million or does
that mean it's our stake in it is like
6.5
because I see on the slide on number
four it says 11 million and change and
then it says 50 funding so it does 11
mil you understand what I'm asking yeah
tap thank you
thank you representative
um the answer is that's the total amount
so it's 11.27 and change total and the
general fund amount would be 5 million
six hundred thirty five thousand four
thank you so that the second capital
project that you see before you on Slide
Five is electronic health record system
this one is for a total amount of 19
million five hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and I'll get you the estimated
General funds amount in a moment
um but that system is really to allow us
and as you heard earlier from the
interim commissioner Lori Weaver where
we have multiple Direct Care Facilities
it's to take those systems and come up
with the strategy to leverage one
electronic health record system as
opposed to multiple
so in hospitals across the country
they've implemented large systems to
manage their medical records effectively
and efficiently between their point of
care services and this is taking that
strategy into the state of New Hampshire
instead of having a different solution
for our New Hampshire hospital and
another solution for Hampstead Hospital
as well as our clean Cliff facility
and we're looking at the opportunity to
leverage a standardized approach of
electronic health record system to
provide those solutions for all of those
areas as well as be able to expand it to
our Behavioral Health area
for to replace an it's over 25 year old
web information technology system that
is currently outsourced to an another
vendor using a.net development
that this proposed solution will be
supporting 2000 users across those
different Direct Care Facilities
and also embracing 300 external agencies
that we contract with currently today
that replacement will allow us to really
maximize our privacy and security and
the reason why that is as a truth is
it's when you build multiple different
systems that do the same thing and you
duplicate the effort it gives you the
opportunities to have more errors and
our goal of having one system is we can
build one very robust solution using
utilizing the resources that we have to
effectively not only make the services
of point of care more effective but also
streamline the privacy and security
components
and then of course the last part is
improved access to the data which really
results in improved patient outcomes
overall
and that general fundament or this
capital budget is 13 million six hundred
and eighty five thousand dollars
and the remaining would be federal funds
thank you
um
I had have we spent money for this or
this health records program or been
proposed in past Capital budgets it
seems like the same same request keeps
coming back is this a different or is
this the first time this has been
thank you for the question chairman um
in previous bienniums we submitted
Capital budgets to improve the existing
netsmart electronic medical record
system that supports New Hampshire
hospital
but those Capital budgets did not
contemplate the acquisition of Hampstead
Hospital nor supporting the behavioral
health components with the area agencies
or glencliffe and so in in potential and
I didn't mention it earlier they're
forensic hospital that were looking to
build out over the next year okay thank
you
for other questions at this time
yes representative thank you Chad thank
you uh so with the
software modernizations with their
health records and uh
the other upgrades just include
devices to go out into the field with
such as laptops and um handhelds when
you go do your case management and
intake
thank you for the question currently all
of our field workers are already already
have established cell phones and laptops
like you see that I have here today for
them to be able to work in the field
however they don't have a system from
which they can connect to and so this
this Capital project for the sea with
solution and the electronic health
record system provides that software or
the Cloud solution that they would use
those existing Hardware infrastructure
to connect to so the capital would not
be funding
that Hardware because they already have
it and we do have it in our operating as
a part of a useful life of a four and
five year replacement program thank you
just brief follow-up chairman thank you
and
uh service contract along with the
these upgrades and the ability to
upgrade ease easily
is that included as well
if I understand your question
representative Terrace um you're you're
indicating yes will this result in a
contract that they would maintain and
operate and upgrade the system while we
were subscribing to or paying for it and
if that is the nature of your question
then yes it would include that in the
terms and conditions of our requirements
for the Improvement thank you
further questions
so at this point I'm going to go ahead
and turn it over to Tammy Nelson our
facilities director to go over our
slide six and
and uh just as one point of clarity the
first two projects that Dave Wieters
just spoke to those were included in the
governor's recommended budget the
Glencliff wastewater treatment
Improvement item it was requested but it
was not approved and and we're here
today just to make a request that that'd
be considered thank you
so you're actually going to get me
before Tammy I don't have all the
expertise that a facilities director may
have on this project but I did want to
convey uh the seriousness and of not
fixing this particular issue of the
wastewater treatment this is a capital
project that's been in play since 2017.
it's on the last leg of getting this
Improvement done we were not included in
the capital budget we've asked for Opera
money we've sought out a lot of funding
for this including a des Grant which
we've been granted for
368 thousand dollars so when we look at
the overall cost of the 1.8 it would be
minus the 368 as well as at this point I
know we're coming back next week to
speak with you about ongoing projects if
there's any money in there that could be
considered to put towards this we have
uh we have clients there that live there
and the risk of this system failure is
just not acceptable for those living
there so I it's a really old system the
facilities self-sustaining and it I I
would hate to see what would happen if
if that failed and like I said we're 90
done with the project so just asking for
um
my um it would seem I I've we've heard
this
time after time
um this wastewater treatment Improvement
um
I I question why arpa funds aren't
appropriate for this purpose and uh was
it just that someone made a
determination that their need was
greater than your need do you have any
background on that I can tell you that I
know that the request was within the
bounds of the Our Fair limits so that is
why we put the request forward because
it was an allowable ask I'm obviously
not in the deciding end so I don't know
if there was another pressing need that
took place over this one but to us it
made sense that this would come out of
that funding source the only reason I
asked is our County alone received nine
point something million dollars and we
were one of the the lowest of all the
counties on the money of which we spent
over two million dollars to study and
modernize our water system
um do you could you tell me if was this
something you folks Glenn Cliff put
together are you relied on Des to follow
this project
well it's really a partnership I mean we
work with um I mean obviously we're out
of Des compliance at this point we're
going to start to get fined as part of
that so you know I think Des Grant
giving us the grant is a sign of that
partnership but we are required to do
all the legwork in terms of getting the
contractors uh lined up and getting the
scope of work and in place and happening
no I understand that the arpa process
when you said you were looking into that
was that the who who did you go through
that process with with gopher
it was a Department of Health and Human
Services request via gopher
did we make it all the way to go for
we we submitted our request to go for
for that we also in our agency budget we
included a prioritized need in the
operating budget
um which which is not currently within
the governor's recommended budget so
we've we've attempted to find a number
of avenues to make sure that we can we
can get this Wastewater system replaced
do you believe your lapses and
representatives here on this committee
will be going through that on next week
um how do you so you're somewhere you
know 50 one one point
or something million away do you have
any idea where your where your lapse
funds how much that might help it it's
my intent to try to find uh sufficient
funds from within from within prior
projects to try to meet this need
um and we will have those details for
you next Monday okay thank you any
seeing none thank you
further representative
yes hi and the and this replacement
there
on the improvements that you referred to
you're confident that you've got
um contractors that will be able to do
that's why I have to look to my
facilities director I mean I think I
know that the history is that we we have
had contractors and they're on pause in
terms of their availability now and
manpower to that I can't really speak to
I just want to say I know many of us
know how remote your the Glencliff
facility is so that's why I asked the
question thank you thank you
I I will say I I did not have the
pleasure of attending our last uh
committee outing to your property and we
we might want to consider that again so
happy to have you thank you
are there is there further to your
only if if you'd wish to go through the
additional details in the Glen Close
slides um we do have some additional
detail of of the risks associated with
failure
um as well as some imagery in the back
that that shows the existing Fields
um through which you will see grass and
other things showing on the last page
that have grown up through the existing
system there effectively compromising it
um we can we can go through a little bit
more detail if you'd like but otherwise
we're good all right
I
I think we're self-explanatory
thank you appreciate your time thank you
look forward to seeing what you can
shake out for money
so while we have a moment next Monday is
technically a subcommittee work session
there are four people who are actually
on the subcutane myself representative
Mills Boyd and Juris anyone else is
welcome to come the way we have but
you're not required to uh the way we
have run it in the past is anyone can
listen to the presentation and ask
questions
uh so you're as good as on the
subcommittee if you do that we won't be
taking any votes what we will do is
simply gather information
uh if you look in the back of hb25
page five
line 22 through to the end that's what
we'll be taking up
and we'll be going line by line through
that with each agency finding out if
they need the money if they are done
with the money if there is something
left out of the bill because it's very
important that we have it absolutely
correct or we get a get an agency in a
position where they have awarded a
contract and they can't pay a bill
because their funding has lapsed
so it's and conversely if
there's funding available as we just
so that's what we'll be doing next
Monday you're free to come but we won't
be taking any votes we'll simply report
back what we find at an appropriate
moment
please the committee meets in this room
and at what time uh 10 o'clock I have
the schedule I just got the schedule
it's 10 o'clock and the last agency is
quick quick question if I could just
thank you
a representative in you to say from
now the lapse extension section is
section 12 it starts on page five at
line 22 and it goes through to the end
of the build
Chris did you have something else to add
on that so Chris if I could while we
have a few minutes so we're going to
finish today with Department of Natural
and cultural resources picking up on the
lap extensions next week
and then where we will have heard from
all of the
Commissioners at that point
Friday you'll have the rest of the
Commissioners coming in so by the end of
Friday and today on Friday you'll have
heard from all the agencies that had a
request in the capital budget
some of those same agencies are going to
come back again on Monday and meet in
person with the subcommittee on the
lapse extensions others that don't have
a lot of lapse extension requests I have
emailed a request for them to provide me
with information on their lapse
extension which will be shared with the
subcommittee and then the full committee
so we're trying to cover all of that as
well
um so yeah by end of day or Friday
you'll have heard from all the agencies
um then Monday we'll do the subcommittee
and then I think next Friday is when you
wanted to start getting into the uh the
nuts and bolts of what this committee
wants to do with the the capital budget
so what what we typically do is we will
start in on that following Friday and
we'll start at the front you've got
House Bill 25 as it was drafted here and
we will just start at the top we'll go
through and we're going to find agency
requests that we all agree with the low
hanging fruit we're going to take care
of first we're going to go through and
we're at that and then we'll start a
discussion on well if and once we have
that settled then we'll start talking
about you know what our priorities are
as opposed to what's in there so the
first first part of that is we go
through and we find you know the the
easier items the programs that are
completely Federal funded you know does
everybody agree on this so that we can
what's happening The Liquor Commission
and things like that Enterprise funds
and so we start working on that and then
we start narrowing in on something that
we may want to tweak or adjust and we'll
start in on that fairly early so Chris
has time then to propose amendments
we'll vote on them as we go and the
ultimate goal by the end of next week I
believe is our schedule that we hope to
have a document at that point in time
so that just that just gives you a
little heads up of where we are in the
process
anybody have any questions
Mr chairman yeah so your goal and I
three o'clock uh thank you David our
three o'clock scheduled public hearing
um on the military
um and requested I would like to bring
forward uh Major General mikalitis
please and whomever else would like to
and when you're comfortable and ready
please go ahead
um thank you Mr chair uh Mr chair
committee members for the record on
Major General David michelitis the
adjunct general for the Department of
military Affairs and Veterans Services
the New Hampshire National Guard with me
today is uh Judy Chen our administrator
so I'd like to cover three things
broadly one is for new committee members
a broad overview of the New Hampshire
National Guard
number two is the four requests out you
will see in front of you for the
Governor's capital budget
and the third item will be two
additional requests that we're asking
favorable um
um favorable support from this committee
so first and foremost number one New
Hampshire National Guard what are we
we're about 3 100 strong both Army Air
state employees and federal civilian
employees
1800 Army 1100 air
1800 army soldiers are geographically
dispersed at 17 locations throughout the
state you will generally see like the
Manchester Armory the Milford Armory the
Littleton Armory generally speaking
we're in 17 armories throughout the
state those armories on state land have
a cost share federal state match
um when we have maintenance facilities
our Aviation hanger here in Concord
those are typically 100 federally
reimbursed
on the Air National Guard we're 1100
strong all IPS are a National Guard base
will we have that new kc-46 refueler so
that's just a broad overview with the
New Hampshire National Guard is when you
look at the four requests that were in
the governor's capital budget
um let's go through item by item and
what they are and what they entail
so again
um our staff has been extremely
competitive and successful in leveraging
federal dollars for new armories and
facilities for the Army National Guard
so we build new facilities on state land
for new construction there's typically a
75 Federal 25 State cost share
so you look at the first one it says
National Readiness Center Edition
that's why you see the the state cost
you're 75-25
um where it says the total cost amount
is 5 million dollars
and so what we'll be doing in Nashville
is at our existing Armory is building on
when you go through item number two in
Plymouth you have this is called the
Plymouth Readiness Center so again we
were extremely successful in competing
in what we call the president's future
years defense plan budget through
Congress
and leveraging a 25 million dollar
project
75 Federal 25 State matching costs share
to build a brand new Armory 20 to 25 000
the third item as you see is a Statewide
building improvements
generally speaking we've only Built one
new Armory in the last 20 years and
that's in Pembroke
a lot of our armories as you probably
have seen in your communities are Cold
War era relics that were built in the
1950s and 1960s
our two oldest ones we have one in
Concord that was built in the 1880s and
we have a Manchester Army that was built
in 1935.
so when you look at that sort of Legacy
infrastructure there's a sustainment
cost to replace roofs replace boilers
and just do General upkeep and
maintenance that just keep them in
service
so item number three is when you see
Statewide building improvements
because it's an existing building on
state land it's a 50 50 state a federal
state cost share so that's what it is
just like we prioritize what routes need
to be replace what boilers need to
replace and go through those old armors
and just replace those those
those type of systems to make sure we
can you know keep maintaining those
facilities
then item number four you'll see this
labeled Nashua hazardous material
remediation
so we know from previous work done at
our national armory that there was old
Tannery waste in our modal pool
underneath the ground
so we know there's a minor environmental
issue there so the money we're seeking
for is 100 General funds is to do
environmental uh we we call it
environmental environmental condition of
property
to figure out the level of where we can
build this edition of where that sort of
waste lies in order for us to build a 5
000 square foot Edition there
generally speaking those are the four
projects within the capital's budget now
I'd like to go to our two additional
requests unless there's any questions
now
are there questions the ads in general
at this point
please continue
so we have two additional requests
um and you should have received a memo
and it's disregard the numbers because
it was in our original budget request
when we did our state submission but
ultimately what we want to do is the
first request is for a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of General funds 100
General funds to purchase land in
Pembroke New Hampshire
what we would like to do is ask the
committee is instead of giving us four
hundred thousand dollars of 100 General
funds for Nashville environmental
hazardous waste investigation is
give us 250 000 there
and move a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for this land purchase
you know we feel a 250 000 is sufficient
to do the environmental investigation
that we need to build that addition
and we're not seeking additional funds
so we would just like to transfer 150
000 into purchase of a budding land at
our Pembroke facility
so for those who may or may not know is
um Pembroke New Hampshire is one of our
sort of landmark facilities it's
relatively brand new and hosts two major
functions
it hosts our Regional Training Institute
in surveillance civilian parlance it's
our schoolhouse
so Envision a community college
so we have the ability to teach military
skills training to different states
throughout the nation so we have about a
hundred thousand square foot building
there that's classroom and dormitories
in addition to that about three years
ago we built a brand new Armory there
save about 250 acres of land with three
major buildings and a track and
supporting um infrastructure and there's
two utility
um companies that have a budding
property that are landlocked that we are
pursuing um the purchase of those
Parcels to just expand our training
footprint there at that facility
the second item that you should see on
the um on the memo is um it should say a
priority
um Milford Readiness Center minor melcon
which is a minor military construction
project
um we were approved by National Guard
Bureau to build a four plus million
dollar addition in Milford New Hampshire
again another about 5 000 square foot
Edition
to an existing Armory with a 75-25
federal state cost share
the reason why that's important number
one is National Guard Bureau approved
approved of it it's in the it's in
congress's budget so we know we have the
federal dollars now we need a staged
cost share it in order to build it
second reason why it's important is it's
one of our largest units in the state
it's our Mountain infantry company so we
have over 125 soldiers who drill in that
building a week in a month
and when you look at the size of the
building it's about 17 000 square feet
it's significantly undersized for the
amount of soldiers and equipment that
subject to your questions that's all I
have
thank you
um yes please
so in your Nashville facility you're
looking to test where the contamination
is so you can figure out where to build
why isn't there money for remediation of
the contamination why are we just
letting it sit and identifying the
locale
so I think the reason why is um
if we know the degree of its location we
it's uh we went through this about four
or five years ago when we did another
Edition there
um as long as it's capped and not
Disturbed
we don't have to go through those costs
to remove that material so we just want
to make sure we know the scope
of area of where that material is
so we know when we dug up the motor pool
five years ago we have a general idea of
where it is and we went through
department environmental services you
know and we would tell like hey you can
just cap this and just don't touch it
for the cost
thank you
further questions
yes represent Mills so just to reiterate
and this is mostly for the some of the
new members in this committee you're as
far as your request number your first
request uh you're not asking for any
more money than that four hundred
thousand dollars you just want to split
into two projects 250
000 to remain in the original hazardous
materials remediation product Nashua and
you want to take 100 the other 150 and
apply it to a land purchase project yes
sir thank you number two
what's the money involved there is that
the entire five million six hundred
thousand dollars yes okay so and again
75-25 cost here so it's going to be 4.2
million dollars Federal 1.4 million uh
100 General funds
so I'm sorry yeah please so that so
basically your second request is for 1.4
million dollars yes thank you
yes representative Jack so if I could
thank you uh so if I could follow up on
that on the last page it says one
million is a state share and that should
yes and the reason why is inflation like
just costly construction so we're
anticipating
once it's designed and put out the bid
it's going to be a higher cost so I want
to make sure we have the right number
I um
before before you leave I just want to
mention we have a lot of the members
that have military time here the adjunct
General said he would stay for a push-up
contest
no I guess and I told the chair that
thanks thank you so much yes
representative
I would ask for this wouldn't be a
question but may I make a comment
it this whole covid thing is kind of a
blur now but a couple of years ago
anyway when the National Guard in Nashua
when the national when the National
Guard people in Nashua were there in
Nashua doing vaccine dispensation at the
high school it was run exceptionally
well it was I I just can't thank you all
enough I have no idea how you pulled it
off but you did cars were lined up they
even stayed patient and well-mannered
and then it was exceptionally well um
just well done and people were very
grateful thank you no thank you thank
you sir I I believe we're all set at
up
time being four o'clock we will uh
pursue our last hearing of the uh of the
day
Department of Natural and cultural
resources we are here with commissioner
Stewart
and her esteemed crew and um
if you would welcome to Public Works and
please present your uh
your budget requests thank you so much
and I appreciate you offering us time on
one of your busier days uh so thank you
for having us this afternoon
um with me is Tom Mansfield who will be
walking you through some of the specific
projects but I just wanted to give some
highlights before we jump in to the
capital budget
um
the Department of Natural and cultural
resources is comprised of five divisions
the division of Parks and Recreation the
division of forests and lands the
division of historical resources the
State library and the New Hampshire
State Council on the Arts
these five divisions share a mission to
protect preserve promote and manage the
state's natural and cultural resources
supporting New Hampshire's high quality
of life and strengthening the
experiences of our residents and our
guests
we strive every day to fulfill our
mission along with specific management
obligations spelled out in various rsas
and over the years this committee has
been instrumental in supporting our
strategic priorities to best serve the
public
we are very enthusiastic about the six
million dollars allocated to dncr in the
governor's capital budget after we walk
through the projects listed in the
governor's capital budget there is an
additional category of projects I would
like to draw your attention to
throughout New Hampshire's portfolio of
lands managed for Public Access there
are many many hundreds of miles of roads
and parking lots that are in a state of
disrepair
a paved parking lot at a busy Revenue
generating State Park provides a double
efficiency for us more striped spots
allow for an estimated 15 percent
increase in available parking spots and
it frees up precious staff time from
parking lot Duty
in the case of the Connecticut Lakes
Headwaters this agency has an obligation
to complete a road management plan as
prescribed by the property easement
we have included an informational
handout which we would like to discuss
today to illustrate our current
situation
simply put we need an updated Road
management plan and Road agreement to
help direct and prioritize Capital funds
and put this valuable Road system that
supports public access to 229 square
miles of pristine property in our
northernmost corner of the state on a
scheduled maintenance program
for the category of roads and parking
lots we are requesting 1.75 million
dollars
with that I am going to ask Tom
Mansfield who I'm sure you all recognize
from previous Capital budgets to walk us
through the 6 million that the governor
thank you
the governor's capital budget request
includes four line items for the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources for a total of six million
dollars
uh I thought I would go through each one
it might be appropriate to take
questions after each one or at the end
I'm happy to accommodate whichever works
best thank you
the first slide item is for roofing and
repairs
this request is our highest priority
it covers repairs and the bird
maintenance projects that are required
to keep the state parks and other dncr
facilities operating and providing
services to the public
that provides a source of funding with
enough flexibility to allow the
department to respond to critical
facilities failures things like water
and sewer pump failures electrical
outages and storm damage
and our list of repair projects
uh
we have representative projects of the
type that we intend to address with this
funding
but we want to make clear that in order
to respond to emergency situations as
they arise it's intended that the list
will be revised with additions
and substitutions over the course of the
biennium
in the roofing component of this request
for funding
we would remove some 80 buildings and
small structures which have been
identified through our maintenance
schedule and our database
we know that maintaining sound roofs on
our building inventory is the single
most effective step we can take to
protect the structures and extend their
that's my summary of the first line on
them shall I go on to the second or can
I any uh any questions on the first item
please continue Tom let me just remind
people that we there was a folder passed
out and so you can follow along in that
folder we printed out these the six
the second line item in the in the
governor's capital budget is for forest
and lands facilities
this request addresses deferred
maintenance facilities upgrades and fire
safety improvements at five division of
forest and lands facilities around the
state
the most significant project in the
group is a set of upgrades at the State
Forest Nursery in Boston
the nursery in bosquin is enjoying a
surge in sales
in the period from 2018 to 2022
the uh the number of sales that they
made went up by 199 percent
and the revenue went up 248 percent
so I guess you could say we're trying to
the main thing we want to do for the
nursery in Boston is to put out a new
seedling storage cooler the seedlings
when they get taken out of the ground
have to be kept cool and moist while
they're being processed sorted and
shipped out so right now we have a
lean-to off the existing Barn
and uh unfortunately the roof structure
was broken by falling snow and the walls
our fractured concrete block
and there's not enough square footage in
it so in order to accommodate all the
seedlings that they're trying to sell
they've expanded into the space of the
ground floor of the barn itself and this
cuts into their efficiency and doing the
sorting and shipping process so what
we'd like to be able to do very much is
provide a new seedling cooler facility
above four thousand square feet
fully insulated with refrigeration
equipment that's energy efficient and
that I think would put them in very good
shape to take advantage of the interest
in the sales and by taking that space
cooler space out of the first floor of
the barn that would allow us to
reconfigure the existing Barn to get a
much more efficient sorting and shipping
operation
and at the same time the State Fire
Marshal has let us know this a few
upgrades he'd like us to do
including enclosing the fire stairs and
taking out the two existing wood stoves
that are in and replacing them we
propose to replace them with an external
wood burning boiler system
so those are big concerns from the State
Fire Marshal's point of view
other forest and lands facilities across
the state that we would like to do work
in include Fox Forest in Hillsboro at
foxfires we'd like to put some
accessible toilets in the Baldwin Center
which is a public meeting room we'd like
to extend the existing parking lot and
pave it so that visitors have a good way
to get in and out
we need to do also fire rated stair
enclosures in the main admin
Administrative Building there replace
the boiler and there's a tractor garage
where the the wood Pier foundations are
rotting we just need to get that back
into structural shape so it can be used
in the urban forestry Center in
Portsmouth
we want to do work on the two main
buildings the main office building
needs an accessible entrance to it right
now right now people come in the lower
level and we have to go down to meet
them rather than be able to get them up
to our offices
in addition the the main stairway in
that building needs to be enclosed for
fire rating
and the learnings Learning Center which
is a big meeting space area used by lots
of groups that come in
there's some egress improvements that we
hope to make and we want to take the
existing kitchen which is a setup that
no longer gets used and replace it with
a setup for caterers which is the method
most people use to bring food into these
meetings we need new finishes floor wall
and ceiling in that building and finally
at the urban forestry Center the parking
lot uh for a long time we've had a
trouble because of the grading around
the parking lot we have accessible
parking spaces but they're not
positioned where they could be most
effective we'd like to be able to adjust
that so we can get those accessible
parking spaces and allow us also to
bring in some sight lighting so that
evening meetings people can get to their
cars after Darkness safely and also pave
that parking lot
moving on to the North Country Resource
Center in Lancaster currently we have a
contract which we're just about to ask
to be approved to replace the roofs on
two of the pole barns but the pole barns
also have large areas where the siding
is rotted and we'd like to be able to
address that
one of the pole barns has a bay that's
heated in the winter time as a workshop
but the insulation is rudimentary so
we'd like to insulate that well save
some energy costs
and we need to enclose the boiler in the
office building for fire safety reasons
also
and finally at healing forest in
Peterborough
uh we'd like to build a new garage with
a workshop for the maintenance that goes
so that's the second line item uh any
questions on that
any questions
seeing none thank you all right
the third uh item in the governor's
capital budget request was for Trails
Bureau equipment this is sort of a two
component request the first part of it
uh is a request for funding that would
go towards replacing the oldest and most
worn out of the state's snowmobile
grooming Fleet
the groomers to be replaced are over 30
years old
the new grow Burns will help the trails
Bureau respond to the recent surge of
interest in snowmobile Recreation
and provide the safe and adequate
grooming of the state's network of some
7 500 miles of trails that they've come
to expect
now the second component of this would
be for funding that would allow the
division to purchase equipment for owned
forces Trail maintenance projects such
as drainage stitching grading and
Culvert replacement there's a category
of projects which are a size that R2 our
crew could handle itself without having
to go through the Contracting process we
think we could affect a lot of
efficiency and cost savings by doing
that
equipment we would need to be able to do
this include excavator tractor dump
shall we move a question
um I believe represent Mills saw that
was just the proposal that you'd asked
for five million dollars that was cut to
one million dollars
that's correct okay however it's
important to note that we have received
some arpa funding for these groomers and
the amount of three million dollars
that's wonderful
they so my question is
um I'm in an area far enough North that
I see this equipment and the efforts
every day of the week and as a business
owner in the area very very appreciative
of this work that's done uh by
yourselves and also by the uh the clubs
so this equipment that's 30 years old
the groomers and they've been holding
that together like I'm sure our old
trucks for D.O.T what what will you do
if you get these replaced will those
will those go to auction or you will
hold on to those for parts if you
thought through to that point
we could also do a museum of historic
Brewers but I'm not sure we have a ski
museum in Conway we could use that the
um
so if you were you're on I fully
understand uh the need for excavators uh
tractors dump trucks and so forth
um
we do we do a lot of our own Bridge
repair many times
and the people uh drive to Concord every
day
and they drive to a site and then by two
o'clock they're turning around and
driving back and very thankful for the
work they do where where do you envision
this equipment being housed would you
move it around through your locations
and is this all equipment that you are
your personnel would then have use of
okay tell me what your plan is here
so it would be staged at the trails
Bureau shops which are located at White
Lake Sunapee
and Lancaster okay and to some extent we
can move it around but it becomes a lot
less efficient when you have to tractor
an excavator long distance like that so
the goal would be to have sort of a
basic set of equipment in each one of
those regions where we could work
directly out of those shops thank you
sir
yes I'll start on the end representative
so to follow up on that
um
excavators cost a fortune and sitting
doing nothing dead time doesn't serve a
purpose for them have you looked at just
trying to get money in your budget be a
little bit more efficient and
particularly when you get three
different locations you can have an
excavator dropped on site for one day or
one week or one month on a quick rental
get full use of it for exactly what you
need and let somebody else deal with the
wait time or set time as opposed to
owning it maintaining it garudging it
and schlepping it around the state
equipment rental is one of the things
that we do also do yep that's
that's currently what what we're
accustomed to doing
we have
um
we have run into occasion many occasions
where we're trying to do fix something
quickly because of a storm or a washout
and that process has slowed us down to
the point where we've had to shut Trails
down and we don't meet expectations of
of the public so we were we were
exploring this as a way where we could
handle a lot of the day-to-day
maintenance ourselves and perhaps you
know if we needed a larger project we
would we would go back to the rental but
the Rental process as it currently
stands isn't as Nimble as we would like
okay
thank you all right follow up
I think if you talked just a commentary
is I think if you talk to somebody you
got a backhoe and a dump truck and rent
in the excavator when you need it you're
going to be fine oh I yeah yeah I agree
I don't know if we want to get too far
we've been we've been told we have to go
through a lengthier process not just the
people that we know have who have done
this in the past and who are ready to go
we need to go through an extensive
bidding process now and that has been a
month two month process that we are
beholden to which has held us up in in a
couple of specific areas
thank you I just to address that issue
I'm assuming you're talking about many
excavators uh tracked tracked loaders
and things like that that are very
purposeful can be moved quickly and and
you know not spending a 250 000 on a
large machine uh represent Kaczynski
yes thank you thank you for taking my
question
um on these groomers how many are you
looking to replace and what is the cost
per unit for those
so uh we were hoping to replace 15
groomers and we're looking at cost
estimates that are coming in pretty
close to 350 000 when you add the
attachment that they need for the
various types of operations that they're
doing
and this winter season has provided us
an opportunity to test out various
equipment from various companies so we
use the snow that we've that we've
received this winter to to really have
our staff using the equipment to know
what we're getting into and and to know
that it would be a perfect match for our
work
thank you further questions
yes a quick question thank you going
back to some of the roofing and the
facilities
have you looked into doing some um
quotable takes on the roofs while you're
replacing the roofs of these uh
particular shelters or uh buildings out
in the uh
yes okay and we've been working with
energy grants uh we put in solar panels
on the Seco Science Center at Odeon it's
been quite effective and of course being
on the Seacoast Science Center it's a
demonstration project as well so it
becomes an exhibit that goes on but yes
uh photovoltaic are very interesting to
us because we have a lot of remote
locations like the Deer Mountain
Campground and Pillsbury so we don't
have uh grid power too and now suddenly
we have an option for ways that we can
power water pumps and things like that
that isn't a gasoline generator all
um I'll go represent Newton and come
back to you representative thank you and
thank you for taking my question are
there other kinds of dedicated funds
that go towards things like Trail Bureau
equipment and management do you get
other monies coming in because I know
you can get a discount I don't have a
snowmobile but I understand you can get
a discount when you register them if you
join a club which does grooming and
trails and stuff so do you guys I just
see the general is where you're trying
to get the money but do you have access
to other
Brian Wilson does
and or Chris Marino who who are here
um the groomers that we're talking about
purchasing in our Fleet of groomers that
we currently have we don't just use
those on staff those are the groomers
that we also lend out to the clubs to
use so it's an it's like a library loan
um for groomers um so the groomers that
we're looking to purchase would also be
accessible to a lot of the club use that
you referred to and then of course you
know when you register your snowmobile
or your ATV that registration goes to
fish and game and then they allocate a
certain percent to us and we take that
money most of it to
disseminate grants to the local clubs so
that they can hire volunteers or
part-time staff to do some of the actual
maintenance work that we're talking
about we only have a staff of about
seven in our Trails Bureau so there's no
way we could cover it all ourselves
thank you um
it looks like
well anyway there's a million dollars
how much are you looking to spend on
this excavation equipment looks like
you're opening up an excavation company
here
and it doesn't say how much is for that
no and the situation is that we have uh
as I had mentioned before some arpa
American Rescue plan funds for uh
groomers and as I said we are hoping to
get in the range of about 15. I
understand that our complete Fleet of
groomers is numbers something like 259
that are being used by clubs all across
the state
so uh the thought was that
with with a three million that we got
out of the 5 million that we asked for
we were going to be able to get close to
the number of groomers we wanted this
money would give us a little flexibility
to
maybe buy out that Fleet and leave us
something in the range of half a million
dollars to put towards equipment for our
our own staff
one more yes follow-up well I'd like to
I agree with representative Eden I mean
I own a company I don't want to own any
more equipment and I don't want to hire
any more employees it's a Contracting is
the way to go especially on things that
you don't do every day it's it just
doesn't
doesn't really make sense to me thank
you
perhaps you could provide a listing of
equipment that you're looking to be in
will do that do that another time and
then take a look at it I will say being
involved in the Contracting end of
it's it's extremely hard number one for
them to find a contractor that can work
with them
and the there are many times if I need a
specialty piece of equipment that I
don't already own it can be very
difficult and time consuming to get that
so I understand that so I think if we
could get that listing of where you're
looking to be and what that ARP is going
to do I think that'd be helpful for the
uh for the members of the committee
please continue moving on to the uh
fourth line item of the governor's
capital budget uh
this is for Mount Washington Summit
infrastructure and ecology study
the Mount Washington commission has just
completed a master planning effort
focused on how to assure the sustainable
use of the summit of Mount Washington
for a number of purposes including
number one a principal Scenic asset for
the State uh a tourist destination I'm
thinking of the Cog Railway and the auto
Road Alpine ecosystem unique in New
England thinking of the Alpine Gardens a
communication site with unparalleled
line of sight transmission abilities a
meteorological Observatory right up in
the jet stream
an attraction for hiking and other
outdoor recreation and finally as a
state park and all the things that go on
in the State Park
the Mount Washington commission
concluded that sound decision making on
issues involving the sometimes Divergent
interests associated with these uses
needed to be based on a thorough
analysis and understanding of this
unique site and the factors affecting it
so this project would be used to fund
the scientific and Engineering
assessment of the environmental
conditions the infrastructure
requirements and the limiting factors at
the summit of Mount Washington
the goal of the assessment would be to
provide a basis for evaluating future
development plans a means to determine a
summit carrying capacity
and guidelines for ecosystem
conservation at what amounts to a very
questions
is is this a project that had any chance
of arpa funding
and secondly is this a project that if
is this looking to be over the course of
a couple Seasons where Times short and
is this a project that we could break in
um thank you
um Senator Jeb Bradley was the chair of
the Mount Washington Master planning
process
um and so I know that he tried to figure
out the best funding source for
something like this I'm not sure if he
had a chance to talk to gopher or if he
initiated a conversation with gopher
about arpa I was not privy to that
this this assessment is is this is the
master plan it's on our website the
assessment is really the major call out
of the master plan
and in order for decisions to be made
about
the Yankee building which is up there
housing all of our really precious
communication stuff which we had an
assessment done several years ago for 14
million dollars we could redo that
building we don't want to do one-off
projects up there we'd really like to
get a holistic assessment of
infrastructure needs to balance the
environmental impacts and and like Tom
said to understand what our capacity is
up there because we could just keep
adding toilets up there all day long and
and welcome everybody up there but right
now it's it's it's really
um a challenge to to predict and manage
crowd sizes as we move forward the hope
is we could put a scope of work together
to do one contract to get this work done
over one season
uh and and then we can move forward
because some of the projects are are
up there is there any is there any so
the
so the auto road is owned by a separate
company
Corporation whatever it might be has
have you approached them as to whether
they might be willing to
again throw some funds in there because
it seems like it would be a benefit for
them also so the auto Road The
Observatory the Cog railroad all
participated in the master planning
process which took about a year
and at one point there was discussion
about
how to how to afford such a large
undertaking
and the conclusion that was voted on by
the members of the of the commission
recommended
they approached the state for the
funding for the study
could you give us a link so we could see
your report please yes right any other
questions
yes representative
can I do something that's not directly
capital budget related
well we'll give you we'll give you some
rope go ahead okay so at the uh Nursery
it's one of the great factors of the
State of New Hampshire government that
90 of the people in New Hampshire don't
know about we have a tree right behind
the state house that's a black walnut I
believe that was a derivative of a tree
obviously George Washington estate
and I threatened to put in a bill for
many years and then real life happens
and it gets put aside to have the
nursery make 234 seedlings from that to
donate either to every town or every
school which would one extend that
Heritage but two give you folks some
recognition and probably pay back in
business but if you don't think it would
pay back enough business I'd be happy to
put in a bill but
just a pondered it it might be a nice
little
statement from the agency I'm looking at
our state Forester Patrick Hackley is
here with us I don't know if you have
anything you'd like to say sure
um
we'd be happy to work with you whether
there's legislation or not we do have a
program the New Hampshire Champion tree
program and we we're
devising a proposal to take seed from
all of our largest tree species in the
state and propagate them at the nursery
so
your timing is good with that idea there
might be an opportunity for us to work
with you and our Nursery manager so
Washington a state Nursery Heritage is
pretty good keep going yeah thanks for
the idea
are there other is is there more to your
presentation uh yes I did draw attention
to the Connecticut Lakes Headwaters as
an example of
um the roads and uh and parking lot
bucket of projects that we
um that we spoke to you about and so I I
don't know how many of you have been to
the Connecticut Lake Headwaters lands up
north they're beautiful and accessible
for Hunting Fishing recreating Trail use
um both motorized and non-motorized and
um you know we're all this agency is
obligated to maintain the roads for the
public access thank you um and and so we
shared a handout to to let you know what
that situation looks like right now with
your permission could I ask a former
speaker and chair of our committee to
come forward and perhaps offer us a
history of that project and I believe
Charles Charlie lebeck is there also I
will yield my microphone okay thank you
for those new members that don't know
the gentleman on the right former
speaker of the house twice and chairman
of our committee for many years Mr
chairman thank you for being here
members of the committee this is Charlie
Levesque and this handouts you have he
had a lot to do with writing it and he
was process started quite a few years
ago now it's hard to believe how long
ago it was but in my opinion and because
I had something to do with it I think it
was one of the best things to say in New
Hampshire ever did
and as I said on the floor of the house
when we had the 10 million dollar bill
to do the bonding to purchase this land
we get one chance and it's going to go
by quick so if we don't do it now the
state will never own it and I think
that's born to be true by when you see
what's happened to other land uh fossils
up north
um the unique thing about this and
Charlie can speak to it too is that this
it's a
this channel is just reminding me this
has never been done anywhere in the
country before where the state has
bought this uh land given out a
conservation holding a conservation
easement but the state owns the roads
and I I can only stress that can't
stress that enough we the state of New
Hampshire actually own the roads in that
uh
hundred and forty six thousand acres so
it's our Our obligation and duty to
maintain those roads because it's what
the public uses to get around in there
whether no matter what they're doing
snowmobiling the road doesn't make that
much of a difference all the time but if
you don't keep the mode and keep the
brush back and things like that you
don't have adequate snowmobile trails so
it does affect winter operations too but
it affects the timber harvesting
we cut quite a bit of Timber on that
land which the timber tax goes to the
local communities but it provides a lot
of jobs up in the area the company that
owns this property they actually
contribute a certain percentage of their
income towards the roads also so it's a
shared responsibility but it I can tell
you it's just so successful
and so important to the North Country
especially but also for the whole state
of New Hampshire I can't I don't know
that they have the figures on the
snowmobile use up on that land but
that's a Statewide issue and I mean it's
it's huge the people at snowmobile there
hiking fishing fishing licenses hunting
licenses goes on and on and on the
people from all over the state in New
England and the country that use this
property and it's unfortunately it's uh
just happened that the endowments that
were set up to do this just aren't
taking care of the roads the cost of
doing this is has exceeded what we have
available the department did go we and
the Connecticut Lakes uh Headwaters
Committee of which I'm a member as well
as Charlie and I have a list of the
people if you'd like to see it who are
on it it's a advisory committee but it's
made up of a number of people most of
whom are from the North country but not
all and we advocate for doing what we
have to do up there to keep the place
going
I will say that one thing this committee
could do and speaking of leasing so I'm
well I was off track a little bit but
it's a problem we we I say we the
Connecticut Lakes
uh folks wanted to buy a tractor and
actually they tried to lease one
it's a nightmare and I I there's a
challenge CR committee to go through
this process and work with not only this
all departments facing the same issue
it's just a nightmare to try to lease
anything it takes months and it's it's a
real problem and it's something you
might want to look into if I know you
have enough to do but you could really
solve a lot of problems if you did that
but anyway that's my little side note
but Charlie do you have something
sure thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee why am
I here uh back when uh this was all
discussed before the legislature and and
the deal was put together I was
consultant uh working for the non-profit
that spearheaded the whole effort the
trust for public land and so this land
was Paper Company land remember we we've
had several PayPal companies own
hundreds of thousands of acres in the
North Country this was the land that way
back when was Saint Regis and Champion
International and then International
Paper uh before the land was secured by
the trust Republic land so that this
public process could happen and as uh Mr
Speaker uh said uh very unique because
the land of the original 171 500 Acres
000 and acres and change is owned by a
private landowner still paying taxes
still cutting the timber uh but the
unique part about it as he said because
these kinds of projects with this kind
of acreage have been done elsewhere
particularly in Maine but uh in all
those cases the private landowner ends
up owning all the roads and it was uh
really uh far-reaching thinking to have
the state on the main roads there
because it gives the members of the
public complete access to that property
and without that not that we wouldn't
have access to it but not in the way
that we we uh we have it now and so the
the important part of recreational
access happens to be
these gravel roads which amount to about
270 miles on the property uh the private
company owns another couple hundred uh
miles of roads that they maintain mostly
for harvesting purposes and so for the
public to get on to hunt fish and do all
the things that they do generate all the
license income and really are critical
to the economies of the three towns
involved Pittsburgh Clarksville and
Stewartstown they need access to the
property they do that on the road system
and back when we did this project did
something else that was unique which the
which was to raise three million dollars
of extra money private money that were
put in endowments that went towards
these some of these activities but as
the speaker said we just don't have
enough in those endowments it's helped
and there's been some maintenance going
on and and I can say that since this was
set up in 2001 no one has ever been
before you saying could there be some
additional money for the road system and
the capital budget hasn't happened to
date not that it's never going to happen
again but I think the intent is that we
wouldn't be coming before you uh every
every single capital budget every two
year period but it might happen again 10
years from now we just the money that's
been available has just been not been
enough and the road system's so critical
so hopefully you'll be able to find some
room in the capital budget to include
something at the at the Connecticut
Lakes Headwaters uh task force the
committee that set up statutorial that
speaker and I sit on we we talked about
1.5 million dollars as part of the
capital budget to make up that that
shortfall that hasn't been there to keep
those roads in order I've spoken too
long probably but I was there from the
beginning and I thank you for the
opportunity to talk about this year and
hopefully you'll consider just 30
seconds please the key thing that I
didn't mention about this whole project
when we started was and why we got the
uh I guess the blessing of the people up
north especially but even throughout New
Hampshire they use that Land We insisted
I say we those of us involved with it
insisted that the traditional uses would
be maintained this property was going to
be left the way it had been used for
everything that had been used Hunting
Fishing snow reeling whatever and that
to this day that is still the case so
that's a good thing if I could missile
vacuum
what or what year did the state
purchases land yeah remember that the
the way that it uh turned out 171 500
Acres was owned by International Paper
000 Acres of that was purchased in fee
by the state and is for the most part
through Fish and Game management now 100
acres actually went to Natural now
natural and cultural resources and the
rest was purchased by a private
landowner
2001 but at the time the state purchased
a conservation easement on that private
land that 146 000 acres and and change
and that means that the current
landowner can manage it for Timber but
really nothing else cannot develop it uh
can certainly sell it in fact this is
the third private landowner that's owned
this land since 2001 and yet nothing has
changed so the construct of a private
ownership with a conservation easement
that assures that it's not developed and
it's it's available for these uses works
because we're on the third private owner
so I hope hopefully that deal was it
2001 when it came before the legislature
that was my question yes yes it was Mr
so
um so we the state managed by
we own the roads now
and so that gives access for the for our
residents to get in out of there so
are are the movement of the residents
only in or near or they have access
through the property for fishing and
hunting and how how much of the year is
that blocked off for Timber operations
or is it just simply posted and you work
around it yeah I mean it's a working for
us so there are some times but uh
usually the roads are not closed because
of Timber harvesting there are signs put
up uh in the winter time that not all
the roads are accessible simply because
of the condition whether they've been
plowed or not but those roads are used
for snowmobiling as well during the
winter time so yeah I mean these roads
are available to to Residents one way or
another pretty much year round thank you
I was completely unaware other other
yes please Roxanne thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
um kind of familiar with that area but
I'm wondering the roads that New
Hampshire has and you're talking about
how important are they to immigration to
be able to travel those roads to get
closer to where illegals might be coming
in I understand it's just recently it's
becoming more of a focus with the
governor and is there any money
available for that does it in other
words with those roads that we've got
does it get the immigration people
closer to where people might be coming
across the border
well it's really not that close to the
Border okay I suppose if you get up to
boundary pond
but they're going to get lost if they
get up there anyway but yeah it's not I
I don't see that as a as an issue
probably not saying the immigration
isn't an issue but I don't think it's as
it pertains to this property would be
it's I don't know how far from the
border we are it goes pretty close in
some areas so do you think they use
those roads immigration
the border patrol I mean I've seen the
border patrol out there before oh yeah
okay they go there yes so reminder there
is a you know a legal uh Crossing at the
tip of Pittsburgh
um and border patrol does in fact
um they patrol all of the the roads that
are associated with it there there are a
few places where the roads end up within
a mile or so of the Canadian border but
there are no roads that cross over
outside of that official border crossing
in the northern part of Pittsburgh these
gravel roads don't cross uh anywhere
near uh the actual border uh with Canada
one more yeah just the statement uh we
we've run into border patrol on Indian
Stream Road before that's why I wonder
if it's important to keep these roads
open
for them in addition to the Taurus and
what have you they're open all the time
I
once in a while a logging operation
might close one of the roads at the
timber company is in charge of perhaps
but all the main roads going through
I've never seen one close I I think
perhaps representative might be alluding
that maybe border patrol should also be
contributing to your road fund I think
that is the point so we could try that
I'll leave that to the commissioner okay
all right any other questions
represent Mills uh thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to put some kind of a dollar
fix on this uh I've heard a couple of
figures tossed around
um anything in particular that we're
looking for a half million a million
million five do we have any set figure
because I do understand this is like a
this is not a yearly ask this is like
one time and this is going to be every
maybe 10 years you have to come back and
ask
yeah thank you yes um so in the um
and sort of the the
bucket the title of the projects would
be for roads and and parking lots um and
the subcategory would be
Connecticut lakes and I believe the the
advisory committee
um have earmarked uh 1.5 million as a an
S A best estimate for immediate
needs that they could tackle
and so the remainder between 1.5 and
1.75 75 would be to support some of the
parking lots that I alluded to at other
state parks okay thank you thank you any
further questions
yes please represent bogert
uh this road weights are these like some
of the roads that are uh going in
between first Connecticut and second
Connecticut Lake bike fire tower I think
one of them was like a Fire Tower Road
where you just go out in the middle of
nowhere and and that's about it and
about the cross signs or just GPS
coordinates and stuff is is okay yep
that's that's right and we also we also
let that uh set up for moose hunting for
the moose hunting lottery and stuff like
that so people can access through there
also okay yeah almost like there was any
number of you know you've got boundary
Pond and first Inlet and all kinds of
places the people kayak and it was a
myriad of things bird watching is one of
the more popular things actually up
there that people come up to do because
they get birds that come down from
Canada and this and that I'm not a bird
watcher but you it's a beautiful ride
down I've done that with my family down
some of those roads not knowing where
we're going but it was a nice ride
anyway yeah that's good
that's good
yes right
I'm sorry representative Jack uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you it's good to
see everyone again uh are you
anticipating you would advertise this in
one Fell Swoop and get it all done in
thank you I'm turning to um Brian Wilson
and Patrick Hackley who are behind me
um I think we would probably break it up
into projects correct yeah
typically we've been able to
um
through a a given fiscal year Implement
around uh three to five hundred thousand
dollars in maintenance uh contracts
um so uh we would anticipate that we
could do this probably over a two-year
period
thank you
any further questions
yes representative oh thank you Mr
chairman uh thanks for answering my
question
so is this item number five on your list
or am I
is it another the brand new one for you
right so this is in addition to the
governors
Capital he did not the governor did not
include this in his capital budget so
we're bringing it to your attention
further further question uh yes uh thank
you Mr chair
so are you going to put in an official
proposal are you just giving us
something verbal now or just saying
anywhere from 500 000 to 1.5 million or
this time or what
an official an official
I didn't mean to speak on a third of the
Jimmy but I'm just trying to figure out
how they're going to do it uh thank you
sounds good we we will await any further
questions
commissioner or anything else you would
like to uh bring I could talk all day
about the agency and all the great work
we're doing but I appreciate your time
and I will follow up with a few things
um I do have one more and I'm sorry
that's okay the uh Tramway project is
put in by the governor uh for not using
Capital funds but using cash of some
sort of arpa funds
um so there's enough monies there to do
that
so do we need to reduce it to a chair
lift what do we need to do we're really
hoping for a tram yeah um this would be
tram three we're celebrating the tram's
80th anniversary this year
um I do have if you're interested I have
the same one-page handout that I handed
out to the Senate it was the Senate bill
Senate Bill 55
that I can pass out or Brian if you
could pass it around just so you can see
how we explained this need to the state
senate
um and uh the belief or the
understanding is that they would grapple
with it to hope that they could find
enough money in the revenue
okay one-time spending
all right thank you anything else you'd
like to speak of or questions well we
have
we will let you out thank you thank you
for the committee that will conclude our
day's business
uh the um
yeah
so the lapse committee on lapse funding
is on Monday
we are here Wednesday and
yeah we're here this Friday Also
but then that following Wednesday and
Friday
so